Hello Freaks,
Rodney and late night style.
It's 10:30 PM here in Los Angeles,
California.
And this episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
audible.com if you've never been to audible.com and you're a fan of,
uh,
either audio books or podcasts or,
um,
I mean they have old radio shows,
they have the opie and Anthony show.
It's,
it's really one of the best resources online for audio entertainment,
uh,
more than a hundred thousand different titles and unmatched selection,
if you will.
Some of the best books that you could get,
including,
um,
uh,
our friend Christopher Ryan's book sex at dawn.
That's on their rent.
It doesn't it?
I believe so,
but yeah,
there's no one else is reading it though.
That's what it was.
And I told him that was bullshit.
Um,
it's,
it's an awesome resource.
And if you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book and 30 free days of a audible servers at World
War z.
How was that?
You saw that,
right?
It's really good.
And then not so good.
And not so good together.
He's dreaming.
He's always,
yeah.
I don't want to say too much.
I don't want to spoil it for anybody.
I enjoyed it though.
It's,
it's an enjoyable film.
It's a fucking Hollywood movie,
man.
It's a big Hollywood movie with Brad Pitt and it's PG 13.
This is a certain amount of fuckery afoot unavoidable.
Anyway.
Um,
you could buy that book or get,
get that book for free.
If you go to audible.com forward slash Joe,
you get one free audio book,
30 Free Days of audio surface from audible audio service.
That's like,
that sounds sexy.
Uh,
we also brought to you by ting.
if you go to rogan.ting.com you will save $25 either off one of tings,
delicious,
sexy android phones or their service.
If you've never used or heard of Ting,
I'm assuming you haven't used him otherwise.
I'm just wasting my fucking time here.
Maybe you have,
and maybe you've heard this podcast a million times.
It's also possible there's no other way to do this commercial folks.
So I got to plow through.
Um,
with ting is a,
a cell phone company that uses the sprint backbone so it's all very high end
service and uh,
they tried to do it in a,
like a very reasonable way.
If you want to cancel,
you can cancel at anytime.
You don't have any contracts.
You also get credit on unused service.
If you don't use a certain amount of your,
your service,
they'll drop you down to the next level,
which is really beautiful.
If you lose,
use less than you thought you would take,
drops you down to the next level and they credit the difference on your next
bill.
It's awesome.
Love Tank,
man.
I used them,
uh,
two days ago at this place that I had my,
eight t iPhone and I couldn't get service there and he like good data service.
I tried my iPad,
which is Verizon could,
same thing,
pull it out.
My Ting device was used streaming on their network,
uh,
from the comedy store and it was just,
yeah,
it was doing [inaudible] has always had sprint.
That's right.
Yeah.
I guess Brent works in places of Verizon.
Doesn't versus me.
No one's perfect at this point in time.
But what they're trying to do at Ting is just give you an option,
an option that's easier to swallow and a it's cool company and we enjoy doing
business with them and go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot com so he shows how
some money you dirty bitch.
We're also boss.
Finally,
this is the last one,
I swear to God and on it but on it's just a given.
I'll try to make it funny.
Uh,
legal zoom.com is our last sponsor,
a legal zoom.com is a website that essentially the,
they lay the framework for legal issues that you would normally have to go to a
lawyer for and pay a lot of money.
Um,
and what legal zoom wants to emphasize very clearly is there not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your specific direction and they can also
connect you with an independent attorney if you need additional guidance.
What they are therefore is to make it much easier to do things like incorporate
or form an LLC.
You can do it@legalzoom.com for just six.
We're just $99 sex on him.
Nora came sex.
It's cause it's evil legal,
legal stuffs,
eval.
I was thinking six,
six,
six.
It's really nice.
Um,
they can also help you out with trademarks,
copyrights,
patents.
If you've got a great idea.
You want to protect.
If you're with family,
you can make a well.
Yeah.
You know what?
That's crazy.
None of us have wheels.
I was,
I was talking to my friends the other day about that.
It's like,
do you have a,
well,
no.
What happens?
Well,
if you live in California,
her parents live in California.
California gets all your shit.
Unless your parents breaking in your house and steal everything.
Really?
Yeah.
I think it's the foreign,
he gets all your shit.
I might be 100%
no,
but I guess there is a thing if you don't have a will,
it doesn't automate.
You think it just automatically goes to your family.
But that's not always the case.
Know what?
I assume there would be a pain in the ass.
The side.
Right.
Especially if you're living with someone,
like if you're living with a girl or something like that,
that girl has a key to your house and she knows you're dead and just comes over
and takes your shit.
That's how I know a little,
a little.
She cares about you.
No doubt.
I told me that was mine with you.
Don't say who would be like seven girls.
All budding heads trying to get in the door.
It has the area and I dare you there.
You just,
there was a humble brag.
No,
no.
Anyways,
we will zoom legal,
zoom.com.
It's a not a law firm.
Remember,
it's a,
they're just trying to help you out.
Um,
and I know there's like some code and I'm supposed to use,
but of course it's not on this copy.
I think it's just the code name is Rogan.
But let me just make sure you get all these guys together.
Just make it Rogan for everything.
I know it would be nice,
but it's not that way.
Bet You lose a lot of
people that are just like,
fuck it.
I don't know it.
I'm just whatever.
Yeah.
Probably right?
It's a code name.
Rogan.
Oh,
sorry.
I was writing from my face.
Not only that,
it's highlighted,
um,
you a special discount from listening to this podcast.
So just enter the code name,
Rogan in the referral box and checkout for more savings.
That's legal zoom.com.
You always have to say it like that at the end,
cause that makes you more professional.
If you just go,
okay,
that fucking commercial's over next.
Like a theatrical ending.
I'm surprised you don't have to do of those like quick,
fast talking things like Tom Segura on their podcast and I have something,
has something similar at the end.
They have to do one of those nine,
the representative they really like and it's like,
they really amazing.
It's weird.
We're,
well,
someone's going to tell us what to actually say on the podcast.
I'm cool with almost anything that's a reasonable ad.
Right?
It makes sense.
If it's something I would use number,
totally use this.
I've used this as long as it makes sense to me,
but uh,
that's,
that doesn't make sense.
I'm not reading off any following Connecticut.
All right.
Dot.
Coms.
The last sponsor,
If you've never been,
go check it out.
Get yourself some fitness equipment.
We've got a lot of new shit.
And if you haven't been into the website before in to the website,
I don't think you go into a website.
If you go onto a website and why is it on and not in?
I mean you're not really on it.
What are you doing?
What are you doing when you go onto a website,
you're going on,
are you going in it?
You're actually entering into it to it,
and then what do you do to go in or do go on it.
So I'm on the website.
You're on the website,
right?
But why is it on?
Because you're like,
you're on it.
You're facing molecule in though,
were in the website.
You're clicking different pages.
You're like,
you know a book.
Oh,
I'm 50 pages into my book.
Or you're in most websites,
like your pictures and stuff.
So I think that's more confusing to most people.
Me,
I'm in most weapons.
Most people go to a website,
they're not in it.
Well then what do you mean like on it
to do retarded?
I'm talking to you.
I'm being serious.
I'm never going to stop saying retarded either.
Fuck you tried to take weight training now.
How dare you?
That's so hard.
I'm taking retard back.
Just some,
I'm putting more words back into the vernacular.
You know what I'm talking about?
I'm not talking about diseases,
dummy.
There's the retarded tranny somewhere going,
oh,
I can't believe you did the voice on the.com.
Uh,
the new prime bells are in a,
if you haven't seen them there,
this,
we hired this awesome sculptor to draw these angry chimpanzee faces for a kettle
bells,
uh,
gives you a little bit of extra motivation when you're working out.
I like to picture that chimp clamping down on my scrotum with his teeth.
That gets me through the last four or five Reps.
Uh,
if you've never used kettlebells before,
what they are is in my opinion,
one of the very best strength and conditioning exercise equipment,
pieces of exercise equipment that you can buy there,
a Russian invention and it's like a cannon ball with a handle on it.
And he's swinging him around and you use your entire body in these,
uh,
these movements.
And I find that that's what really applies to not just physical,
um,
uh,
sports.
But if just if physical movement,
physical movement,
like I'm picking things up,
the ability to move stuff around your house,
you,
you gain a balance sort of strength.
Whereas a lot of people,
one of the problems with people who,
uh,
don't use a professional trainer or don't exactly know what you're doing.
You can develop imbalances,
uh,
with your body because maybe you use your arms too much.
You don't use your legs enough or vice verse and it can be,
it can be a mess.
Um,
one of the best things you can do if you're going to think,
if you're thinking about kettle bells or any kind of exercise thing is to hire
someone who's really good,
who can show you what to do.
You can learn a lot of stuff from youtube,
but you really should have someone sort of correcting subtle things in the way
you're moving,
just to make sure that you have good form.
Use a lightweight to begin with,
try to try to be very reasonable about what you're trying to do and then build,
right.
You're right it down and build.
And when you do do that,
you will get an immense set sense of satisfaction.
The sense of satisfaction that you get from pushing your body and getting your
body into a good state of physical fitness.
It's not just a vanity thing,
it's really good for your health.
And uh,
you know,
I talk about it all the time,
but it's very hard for people to stop eating donuts and get off the couch.
It's very difficult to choose to have a salad instead of a shitty cheeseburger.
It's hard.
It's hard to get your shit together.
But if you can get your shit together even just a little bit,
you'll feel better.
That's a fact.
I lost eight pounds in two weeks.
Have you really?
And that's after quitting smoking,
which is like usually a gain weight with a few you sexy bitch.
Brian Ryko looking at health,
he's a,
he's cutting back on his coughing.
He's doing all kinds of shit.
Next thing you know it,
but taking t plus,
I need some of that.
Get some,
we got some,
I'll give you some,
I'll bring you some,
a next podcast.
Cool.
All right.
That's the end.
Uh,
use the coordinate Brogan.
That's r o,
g a n and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
my friends,
Rick Doblin is here and we are going to get to the bottom of some shit.
Please cue the music
experience podcast by night.
He made it.
I did.
Rick Joplin,
who is the head of maps or if you uh,
have never heard whether the,
it's called an acronym where it's maps or is it yeah,
it is.
Cause it's,
you say it right when you don't say it.
It's an abbreviation.
Is that what it is or which we tried to figure that out once.
Um,
but it stands for the multicultural as far it is,
what Google is for it.
But somehow or another,
I'm not quite,
I don't totally have it together.
Multidisciplinary Association for Psychedelic Studies.
Uh,
you founded this.
Yeah.
And I was surprised to discover it.
It has the most syllables of any organization in
the nonprofit world for drug reform
really?
Well,
it's a very interesting title,
Multidisciplinary Association for Psychedelic Studies.
That's what I love about it.
It's like you're coming at it from a whole bunch of different angles.
So as he just doctors,
it's not just chemists,
it's a whole bunch of human beings.
Yeah.
And I had learned from a previous nonprofit that when you want to create a
nonprofit,
it's good to try to make it as broad as possible.
The purpose as you see different strategic ways to do things.
So I made it multidisciplinary,
which means we could look at psychedelics from virtually any perspective,
um,
association to mean that it's publicly supported a nonprofit.
And I had images of,
you know,
tens of thousands of people banding together to support research in different
areas.
Um,
psychedelic was a big choice,
actually,
whether we should use the word,
whether we should use a different word,
whether we should use a euphemism.
And so I felt like I wanted in this kind of second coming of psychedelics into
the culture 40 years after the crackdown that I wanted there to be a certain
transparency.
And so I wanted to use the word psychedelics so people knew what I was doing and
I was hoping that we can change the cultural connotations from what it was in
the 60s of psychedelics,
uh,
rebellion,
dropping out,
uh,
you know,
finding your own sort of private utopia somewhere,
certain kind of,
um,
not integrated into the culture.
And now that's,
I think the arc of the story is psychedelics came at a time when culture wasn't
really ready and brought all sorts of things to the surface.
And over the last 40 years,
our culture has gotten ready with hospice centers,
with birthing centers,
with Yoga,
meditation,
all the things with flotation tanks,
all the things that were too hard to integrate at the time,
death and birth and just raw emotions that,
and also this globalization and growing sense of global spirituality.
Now our culture is ready and I think we can over the next 10 20 years integrates
psychedelics without the connotation of rebellion.
But to enhance what we're all doing together.
That's interesting.
I like the use of the word psycho dogs cause you're owning it and that is what
it's about and you know,
and it's,
it's shouldn't be something that people are afraid of or afraid of adding to
something because it'll somehow or another make it silly or make it,
oh psychedelics.
You know,
people want to dismiss it and they can much easier.
Owning it is,
is I think is very important.
And there's no other word that's even better.
No.
Hallucinogen was used by the government.
It's like you're fake.
Yes.
I don't like that feeling either.
Hallucinogen always makes me feel like I'm seeing something that's not there.
Yeah,
that's the idea.
Yeah.
It's not real and don't know anything about psychedelics.
They imagined like literally like imagining someone in the room with you and
that guy,
it doesn't really exist.
The word before that in the 50s was even worse.
It was psycho.
My medic.
Ooh.
Which means it mimic psychosis.
Well it doesn't.
Some people should be careful.
It does.
It does bring in all parts of ourselves.
I think we all have those kind of parts where they're not really integrated and
it seems extreme and you let the emotions carry you so that the safe place we
have to be careful I think is true.
But the bad trip,
the difficult challenge,
the death rebirth,
it's in all of us as are these psychotic states.
I,
I actually had what I felt was probably the most psychotic or diluted state of
my whole life was doing LSD and a flotation tank.
Wow.
I can imagine.
So self examine story.
Anyway.
Yeah.
I'm not an LSD person.
I never have tried it because I've never trusted anybody in the right way to get
it.
But I've done a lot of time in the tank on especially on high doses of edibles,
edible weed,
that insanely uncomfortable feeling that you get.
Will you get,
you could examine story about shit you did in high school.
Like really in depth.
Yeah.
In high school.
Good for yeah.
And the tank does that on its own.
So the tank with that together,
it's,
whew.
Yeah.
Well imagine acid in the tank would be a similar experience.
Well I grew up reading John Lilly in the 1971,
actually,
but it was before that was programming and Meta programming and the human bio
computer.
And that was so technical and complicated.
I had to spend like a whole day on each page or something that just like cam at
figure this stuff out.
It was so early computer discussion,
discussion and language about and how the brain in that parades,
yeah.
He was a real pioneer.
Like a real pioneer.
I mean that dude was out there.
Yeah.
But he went too far out and he wasn't grounded in his last,
uh,
30 years.
We're kind of a sad tragedy,
I would say.
Wasted potential.
Um,
it was that because of ketamine,
cause he got involved heavily with Ketamine,
which has some pretty disastrous results.
Yeah.
Ketamine is the most addictive of all the psychedelics and I physically
addictive,
not so much physically,
which,
but more this,
a reliable escape that and this delusion of superiority.
So was their withdrawal.
I'm not in that same way as heroin or it's not like physically it's just a
psychological addiction more so there's a shift in the attitude and,
but what I think was the problem with John Lilly more than before,
the ketamine was a certain kind of brilliance that was unbalanced and he was
kind of arrogant and I don't think he was patient and he was way ahead of his
culture,
you know,
way ahead.
And yet when he saw the crackdown calm,
I think he,
he sort of took this superior position and just felt like he's not going to work
on a
political struggle or even a scientific struggle to get these tools back.
He kind of withdrew.
And even from boy he just had this um,
somewhat self destructive aspect too.
I read a lot about him and I met him and I actually ended up,
I'm trying to do Mtma therapy with him when it felt like he was really going
downhill from the ketamine and from cocaine and wow.
Yeah,
that's intense is the word is kind of my hero.
One of he and Stan Grof,
and I would contrast them that Stan is doing fantastically as traveling.
The world is totally together and a major inspiration who is able to integrate
into his life.
Whereas John Lilly was,
you could say arguably as brilliant but went off the track.
Yeah,
it's,
it is possible.
That's one of the real issues with anything that completely alters the way your
mind works is that you could get into that too much.
She can get into that more than reality and lose your grip of this one.
Well,
it is reality.
It's just a different view of reality.
Um,
and I think that the grounding part and what we emphasize in our psychedelic
therapy is that it's the integration work more than the experience itself that
produces longterm benefits.
So then you can have these unusual experiences,
but what do you bring back from them and how do you integrate that into your
daily practices so that it's anchored so that you can try to get there without
the drug.
It's like this evolution process where you learn something.
And I've found,
at least for me,
the psychedelics are something that I can work with through a lifetime,
through a lifespan that I've learned.
Some people say when you get the message,
hang up the phone.
And I felt that there's been different messages at different stages of my life
and that I'm more able,
although it's still really hard,
you know,
to hear those things,
those the self critical stuff like what he did in high school or what,
you know,
how you try to hear the message underneath the criticism.
And um,
I learned that a lot during an Ibogaine experience.
So I've seen that these experiences can have these lasting changes,
but that they don't always,
and they don't have to.
And particularly when you had these experiences that are unbalanced,
the drug starts wearing off and you haven't come to a new balance.
And during those periods,
the best solution at least is to continue therapy and do another session.
And that's where people often back off and they kind of free something in place
that's at such a deep level.
It's hard to get to that deep level to move it forward.
Yeah,
it's um,
it's,
it's a very personal thing,
isn't it?
Like where you start from to,
you know,
for some folks it's like they've already,
they already have issues with reality itself.
They have issues with being grounded,
with being calm.
And I mean it's some people you could just,
you know,
you could just get them high or they could have some sort of psychedelic
experience and they would be able to assimilate it into their life and they
would benefit from it almost immediately.
Whereas other folks almost needed to be.
I think education is one of the big ones that were really lacking in this
country when it comes to these things.
And the word Shaman is such a,
such a loaded word because it's like healer,
you know,
when someone says their healer,
all of a sudden you,
oh,
okay,
you know,
what,
what other dumb shit or you're going to say next,
you know,
are hollow therapeutic approaches based on the idea that there's an inner healer
and it's the support that we provide to help people heal themselves.
So there's a power dynamic often in shamanism where sometimes the shaman is even
the only one that does the drug and then heels you.
Hmm.
It's not teaching you how to heal yourself so that we have this idea that like
the body heals itself.
If you get a cut that the psyche has these self healing mechanisms and brings
things kind of to the surface so that it's not so much reality and psychedelic
state.
It's almost like reality and more reality.
And we know that from a Fmri brain scan studies that were recently done in
England with Psilocybin,
that what it does in the brain is different than what we had been thinking and
we had been thinking that it makes the brain speed up,
that that you know,
some things work even faster that,
that your perceptions are going.
And actually what it does is it makes parts of the brain slow down,
but it's the filtering parts of the brain so that we have enormous volume of
perceptions coming to us at any one time.
And that's kind of what you can see in the tank to that when you start quieting
everything down,
you can really,
you know,
think in different ways.
But we have this enormous amount of information and we only narrow and look at
some of it what we need to do either for survival,
for we focus and the controlling the filtering parts of the brain are what
psilocybin slows down so that they work less well.
So you get more of a flood of what's already there.
What is the mechanism,
the filtering parts of the brand.
When you say the filter in parts of the brand,
what,
what are those?
Um,
they're generally linkedin,
what's called the default network,
the default mode network.
There's um,
and here becomes kind of a practical side of the work that I do,
which is basically trying to develop a psychedelic drugs into prescription
medicines and marijuana.
So from the FDAS point of view,
um,
you have to show something safe and efficacious,
but you don't have to explain how it works.
So therefore,
I haven't really focused on that.
So,
I don't know the answer to your question because,
um,
it's neuroscience and I don't need neuroscience to know the exact quadrants,
the brain.
So I've kind
of got,
um,
people I work with and other people I rely on another scientist to do that part.
It helps if you have an explanatory mechanism,
but at the same time it's not necessary.
So what I've done is tried to be strategic and tried to focus on the stuff
that's essential to move the culture forward,
to create legal context for psychedelics to show that they can be used
responsibly.
Why is asking more for my own edification?
I wish I could answer you.
I always,
one of the,
I think I read that very study about quieting areas of mine.
I thought it was really fascinating and um,
I attributed it to uh,
the,
the idea being that we are filled with noise.
You know,
that our mind is filled with noise.
Our mind is filled with concentrating on a bunch of shit that's not really
important and that that gets shut off and then you can sort of tune in to
whatever the fuck it is that you took and uh,
whatever it is that you took that's doing something and yeah,
I don't see it so much.
That stuff is not important,
but it's not as important.
I mean,
you need to do certain things to get through the day,
so you need to have a narrower focus.
Maybe not important.
Wasn't even what I should've said.
It's just,
it's not that it's unimportant,
it's just sometimes there are things in your life that aren't that important,
but they take primary focus,
they take center stage,
you know,
whether it's an argument that we,
you got with a friend over almost nothing.
Something that can be addressed,
you know,
really easily and quickly probably.
But whatever it is,
it's bothering you.
Should I say something because I really feel like I'm being slighted and no fuck
with you all day until you actually have the conversation with the person.
And it can be a million other things.
Could it be financial issues that you have?
Could be something's wrong with your house and you have to pay to get it fixed.
And all these things just constantly chip away at your ability to focus on the
now and to enjoy,
uh,
just to enjoy the experience of life itself.
Yeah.
I've never really felt comfortable kind of meditating to try to let all those
things go because I get into this state where I have this idea of something
should I do,
I should do.
And I think those things that you mentioned are really important.
How you relate to your friends.
Those are words,
those are the most important things of life.
Not that at least important,
but I've always felt like when I'm,
if I were to be meditating,
this idea will come up and I'm supposed to just let it go.
And I thought,
why don't I just do it?
I'm more outer focused in,
for me,
the,
uh,
jogging and being stoned are like meditation.
Oh,
it's definitely the meditation.
Yeah.
Jogging stone is a trip.
It's very different than,
than just exercising.
Yeah.
Fight.
I have,
but I think that this idea of creating a space like in the tank or like a
therapeutic setting where you're not paying attention to all those daily things
where you can sink deeper to,
um,
other questions of life that that is really important.
You have to kind of consciously create a space for that.
Yeah.
The,
the things that always up in trips,
um,
for me that they're,
the,
the uncomfortable things are always things that I really should be working on
anyway.
It's always like,
maybe I've hit an imbalance and I focus too much on this and not enough on that
or,
or whatever it is.
Those,
those moments where it hits you,
it's like you should've known that anyway.
And if you,
if you knew,
if you were living in a harmonious way,
we wouldn't have to tell you this.
All right,
so get it over with.
Figure that out.
And every trip that I've had that,
that,
where that's happened,
they've only been a few of them that are really liberal,
like super uncomfortable,
just really bad.
But those always,
I benefited from those,
every one of them.
Now?
What do you mean by bad?
I don't mean bad.
Uh,
I mean,
um,
uncomfortable like especially with the eating,
eating marijuana,
the eating marijuana thing.
Yeah.
A lot of folks do not give that the proper respect and that's why they freak out
and call the cops.
If I'm sure you heard the great video of the police officers who stole marijuana
from someone they pulled over and then made pot brownies and then got so high
they panicked and called the police.
They call the ambulance,
call the ambulance.
He was saying right there.
Have you heard that before,
Brian?
Yeah,
we played it on here.
That's right.
He played it.
Oh sure.
Play it just for the goof.
Cause it's fucking ridiculous.
These poor people,
but they didn't know these,
these dirty cops is that marijuana and when it's processed by your liver,
when you eat it,
it's produces something called 11 hydroxy metabolite and incredibly psychoactive
material.
It's not like the THC high at all.
It's a totally different experience in much stronger.
And that's why a lot of people think that like the aide cookie,
that it was laced like,
oh my God.
So when he lays this was something,
I know you're taking a totally different drug.
Yeah.
We do harm reduction at festivals to try to,
uh,
imagine a post prohibition world.
So at burning man,
boom,
other festivals where we provide,
um,
an organized teams of therapists and others that work with people that have
difficult trips and people at the most people come sometimes is for eating too
much marijuana.
Yeah.
People don't realize how this,
this easily can be as strong as any psychedelic g tech and that's not bullshit.
And listen to these poor folks
calling nine one one call.
You will hear,
tell him where the information had been removed.
Boy,
Michael.
Yeah.
Can you please send rescue?
I think I'm having an overdose and so is my wife.
Okay.
You and your wife?
Yeah.
Overdose of what?
Marijuana.
I don't know if they had something in it.
Oh,
okay.
The police and rescue.
Okay.
How old are you?
I'm 28.
29 years old.
And my wife is,
uh,
25th.
Please calm 20 sec.
Yes,
please.
Hey,
I think paint also.
What have you guys been drinking tonight too?
No,
that's it.
Is there any weapons in your house?
No.
Please come.
Okay.
Are you guys like you guys have fever?
No,
I'm just,
I think we're dying.
Oh,
how much did you guys have?
A,
I dunno.
We made brownies and I take what dad?
I really do.
Okay.
At.
Well,
how much should you put your mounties?
I don't know.
I,
I hit him back.
Um,
my wife and I did too,
but come here.
Okay.
She's on,
she's on the living room ground,
right?
Yeah.
Barely breathing.
I think so.
Okay.
Pardon?
Did I?
Yeah,
I could feel it.
She's laying right down in front of me.
Time is going by really,
really,
really slow.
Pardon?
Yeah.
How much did you buy
this?
Please send rescue.
It's probably like a quarter ounce total.
Yeah,
we did.
Okay.
Why is that funny?
I'll tell you why.
It's funny cause he can't die from it.
The only way pots going to kill you is if you take 25 pounds and he dropped it
off of a CIA drug plain and it lands in your head.
That's how pots going to kill you.
You could probably get a heart attack.
A good movie could kill you if that's the case.
You Pussy.
Yeah.
The other question is why did they think they would die and it's not just
because their heart was racing or things like that that the judgment day it's,
well it's like these feel during parts of the brain that the pie when you eat it
like that,
it's kind of very powerful.
It is like tripping code and so your sense of who you are.
He was pretty logical.
He was pretty good at answering the questions.
He had some problems.
So some of that,
but I think people confuse ego death with physical death and ego,
death of letting go of who your narrow sense of who you are and opening up into
something very scary.
And so people have defenses and they converted into,
I think I'm dying because it feels like that you,
that you is dying in a way.
That's interesting.
But I mean,
don't you think also he's just fucking panicking and thinking that he overdosed
on a drug and just shitting his pants?
I can maybe not even an ego death.
Just absolute fear of the fact that you don't know what the hell was in there
and you,
well,
he knows he made it.
It was pot.
He knew what it was.
He just got taken by surprise how strong it was.
But he said he doesn't know if there's anything in it.
Well,
it's what you said right before,
as people start thinking it was laced with something that it's not.
So,
I mean,
I think the guy thought he was dying.
Well,
I thought I was dying on weed before I caught it.
Really physically if that you're dying.
Yeah,
it'd be because I had something in my life,
I always thought it had something wrong with my heart,
you know,
so I had,
uh,
like as a kid would pass out
and black out and just like fall to the ground.
I had to take the stress test as like an eight year old kid.
Like,
you know,
taking,
running on the treadmill and stuff.
No,
they could never find out what happened,
you know,
then it would happen again like four years later.
So like growing up,
I always had this thing like,
all right,
I have a bad Boone heart type shit.
Like it's,
it's like it's a broken heart or there's something with a valve that they just
haven't detected.
And so when I smoked too much weed,
I immediately thought I felt my heart and I'm like,
all right,
my heart is fucked up.
So I,
it wasn't that the weed was killing me,
but it might be doing something to what I already thought I had a problem with
my heart already,
you know,
type thing.
In other words,
you were panicking like a little bitch.
Yeah.
When you thought you were going to die.
When you hear,
when you feel your heart double beat,
you know when it just like bup up,
up,
pump,
you know that starts doing shit like that.
You certainly mind fuck yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
I didn't know you had that thing though.
I didn't know that you blacked out.
I blacked out five times in my life.
Wow.
You know,
and they've tried everything.
They've done tons of tests.
You know,
it's only been like the last maybe five years.
I just don't give a shit about that anymore.
You know?
I don't know what happens and I don't ever get panic attacks anymore anxiety
anymore.
It just went away.
I mean I've been using a lot Molly lately,
so maybe that's why
you,
you probably look good evidence for my therapy.
I believe in that a million times over storms or anything,
especially when you're with a loved one and there's definitely something minute.
I don't think over,
I don't think it's a competition or a race.
I think they all have their own little impact.
We're talking about psychedelic medicine,
psychedelic spirituality,
and it's the whole range of drugs at different times at different places.
But yeah,
we did it.
The other thing about psychedelics is it can,
there's a lot of states that can be achieved naturally and I think in the
pursuit of a psychedelics as a discipline,
as,
as something just to truly legitimately study.
I think one of the things that they're going to open up is what yoga does to the
body.
Yeah.
Yoga does something,
they're intense.
Come on Brian Class,
stop it.
Get it,
get.
If you,
if you take a really strong yoga class and you get through it,
you feel like your high
yeah.
Yeah.
And I,
I am aware of friends,
longterm yoga practitioners,
long term meditators who have found that it's not either or that you can,
when you're practiced in these ways too,
that you can have a psychedelic experience.
You can go to a deeper place and then you can work,
you have a better sense of where you want to be and you can work sometimes for
years to grounded and integrated.
And it's,
it's this flow back and forth.
So I think the overreliance on psychedelics can prove to be harmful because
you're not doing the integration or with John Lilly,
you're escaping,
but the idea that you'll stay somehow or other,
you know,
pure and do things all on your own,
there's a certain kind of,
um,
slowness or egotism about that.
It's,
it's not,
uh,
inappropriate to admit sometimes that we need physical catalysts.
We need help.
We need tools.
Sometimes our defenses are so strong.
No,
I don't think it's an either or situation.
I don't think there's anything we,
for whatever reason,
we have this idea in our head that taking something to get somewhere as a
weakness.
You know,
there's a lot of people that believe that,
that taking a drug to achieve a state like,
oh,
you can't deal with reality.
You're weak,
you know?
Yup.
There is that.
But then you switch it to cars.
Like you'd take a car to get psych suck a plane and a car to get here.
Yeah.
No,
you could definitely look at it that way.
I just think the,
the idea is very strange when we know that,
look,
our,
our bodies are these weird biological machines that were constantly feeding
different things too.
We're constantly giving a different kinds of nutrients.
We experiment with the diets,
we experiment in our carbohydrate balance and our protein,
but we experiment with all these different things.
But when it comes to taking a plant,
especially something like mushrooms sets,
we've documented many thousands of years of use and to decide all of a sudden
that this is a weakness and that this is,
you know,
just unnecessary in society as if our society is perfect in every way.
And you know,
yeah,
no need for self examination here at all.
Yeah,
well we're actually an anomaly as far as society goes cause most of them have,
uh,
the use of drugs,
the use of altered states in some kind of sanctioned manner.
It's repressed and prohibited throughout our lifetimes.
We kind of have a sense that maybe that's the way it's been large parts of human
history,
but it's not been that way.
They're encased in a religious rituals or different kind of cultural context.
But they're not prohibited and they're respected.
And I think that's where we've lost touch with that.
And there's so much coming from people finding it on their own through various
methods that the culture is changing.
I think it's definitely changing.
And I think what's really crazy is that the people who are suppressing
psychedelics,
that people who seek to suppressant are the ones need them more than anybody.
Well exactly.
So our study right now that we're doing,
and again the with Mtma for posttraumatic stress disorder,
I owe it to the point to Brian,
you're the poster boy kid revelations,
just the first one for tonight.
Um,
so we're working with veterans and then we've also expanded it now to work with
firefighters and also with police officers.
And I had pretty much given up hope about getting a police officer actually to
volunteer.
So we've had 15 people out of 24 the 15th is going through screening.
The first 11 we're 11 of them were vets and were firefighters and now we have
the first police officer that is going through screening.
So the people that are repressing it in some ways they do need it the most and
how to help them relax about it,
at least to let others or to explore themselves.
But at the same time I've been trying to get my father and mother to smoke pot
since I was 20 years old and they've never once done it,
but they're totally supportive of what I do.
They think it's a tremendous,
but they will not.
There was one time when my mother had um,
uh,
some pain.
She had fallen down in,
in her leg,
was really in pain and she said she would try marijuana for pain and I got home
like a week later because she's in a different city and she said then she wasn't
in enough pain anymore.
Oh Wow.
I was too slow for a mom.
Well,
you know,
there's a lot of folks that are a prisoner to that propaganda that was just
really shot home from the 30s on.
It's,
yeah,
it's a pretty incredible feat when you stop and think about the effectiveness of
marijuana and not just for people like as far as like a a drug and not just for
its psychoactive properties,
but just the plant hemp itself.
Just all the amazing benefits it has for as far as nutrition,
construction methods,
making paper and clothes and all these different things.
The fact that somehow none of that kept that from the public and kept it under
wraps and kept the from really from the average person's database.
Most people,
if you ask him about marijuana being illegal,
what about hemp?
Oh,
it's isn't the same thing.
Like what does that mean?
People don't even know what the fuck can't,
is
the,
what they should know is that the largest hemp importing country in the world is
the United States and the largest hemp x sporting country in the world is China.
So why is that?
Why we've kept it narrow legal.
We're inputting it,
but relating other people grow it.
It's incredible.
But that's,
that's all the largest producer of,
of,
of pharmaceutical drugs is United States.
That's why,
and that's really what it boils down to.
The pharmaceutical drugs without a doubt don't want marijuana to become legal.
And one of the doorways from marijuana to become legal is him.
His people.
Figuring out how incredibly effective hemp is for so many things that we use
other stuff for besides the psychoactive properties.
Just it's a makes it fantastic protein powder.
My,
the company that I'm involved with on it,
my friend Aubrey and I,
we,
when we was first you met Aubrey up in San Francisco,
when we first started talking about a Hamp,
we,
we thought,
well maybe we could get a farm in this country and you know,
grow this hemp hemp seed and then use it for the protein powder completely.
Non-Psychoactive when we found out you can't even do that.
Like even though hemp is legal,
I didn't know that.
They literally can't be grown in the United States.
We buy it all from Canada.
Yeah.
One of the,
um,
people on maps as board of directors is David Bronner.
And so from Bronner soaps,
his grandfather started and he's been very active in that hemp hemp oil soap.
They use hemp oil and writing like a crazy person documentary on Netflix about
him.
Yeah.
Oh really?
What's it called?
I think it's called Doctor Bronner's.
Magic soap.
I have a friend,
so I'll use 80 bravo.
That's all he uses forever.
Well,
David and his brother Mike have built this business from,
their father was kind of obsessed.
They are their grandfather and they knew that.
So they took this business over when it was really fragmented and like a million
or two a year in sales and they've built it up to over 50 million,
50 million.
And they in sales not just hope at other products and they don't advertise,
they don't advertise.
What they do is they do now Bronner's soap,
kill it,
go get it.
Well,
here's your local.
What they do is a social justice illegally activism.
They do,
um,
they focus on fair trade and other things.
But what David did about four months ago or five months ago is he constructed a
cage,
a metal cage,
and he had someone drop it off with him inside it in front of the White House
right across the street.
And he was processing hemp plants.
He had gotten real hemp seeds.
He had grown it in the United States and he was processing it into hemp oil.
And he did this as a protest.
And the cage was to prevent the police to slow them down while they tried to
stop them from doing it.
And he actually got convicted and it had to do public service.
But what he was trying to show is that hemp,
which can be a food,
which can be any number of different things and can be grown in the United
States,
was a crime.
That,
and just making it into hemp oil to put on his bread was enough to put him in
jail and to give them,
uh,
penalties.
It doesn't make any sense and it's insane that it continues to go on.
It's one of those weird aspects of our society where you look at it and you go,
well,
there's gotta be a reason.
Let's,
so let's search for a reason.
And you look for a reason and it literally doesn't exist.
I think there are real strong reasons that go really deep that make us easy to
miss them.
But I think they're the natural fear that each of us has for when our social
controls are relaxed,
that will become a whatever we will become.
It's what you talked about even in the tent,
when the t the flotation tank,
when things come up,
you know,
it's just people are scared of the compromises that they've had to make to live
in society and have their basic urges and what happens when they're not in
control.
And that's what these drugs represent.
And the 60s also represented not only these people that let themselves get out
of control,
then they want to leave and drop out and then they want to change things.
And it,
it was a difficult,
people are scared of their own.
I feel it in myself that I'm scared sometimes of,
uh,
you know,
my deep desires or you know,
oh,
that you just created a meme,
sir,
too.
Right?
I feel like I'm scared of my deep desire.
I didn't need to see here's some 1970s music playing over that.
Yeah.
So I think that's a big part.
Speaking of that,
Jim Kelly died today,
man.
The great karate master,
Jan,
Jamie clued me on that.
A dude from enter the dragon breast of pieced.
Mr. Kelly.
Sorry.
Yes,
no,
no.
That's important to think about how short our time is.
It is,
right.
It really is.
That's why we got to get all these anti,
we'd people high or at least help them see more human rights,
more freedom.
Why should they tell us what to do?
And I think the other part of it is that the drug laws have been used for social
repression against minorities and either Mexicans or blacks or you know,
hippies and that letting loose of that avenue of control.
There's in the power system.
And I think what we're needing to do to integrate these things,
to legalize marijuana,
to legalize gay marriage,
these kinds of things where people see it's not going to tear apart the fabrics
of society,
that people can make contributions and that people can also learn to deal with
their deep desire so that they're not so scared of him.
Yeah.
We've made some massive headway as a culture because of that.
Um,
the,
the gay marriage thing,
the fact that I'm Idaho got it before California,
that that hurt,
that really hurt.
There was like,
how's how dumb you fucks.
And the,
the,
the name of the bill that eliminated the ability for gay people to get married,
the marriage,
but it was it fencing,
defensive marriage act.
Oh God.
How about if you really want to defend marriage?
I'll be stopped.
People from getting divorced.
See how that works out.
You really want to defend marriage.
Tell people they have to say together.
That should be a t shirt right there for real.
You want to defend marriage.
Marriage is ridiculous.
This is coming from a person who's married.
It's a stupid idea.
It's a legal contract that you signed with another human being and then you're
going to bring in a bunch of other people if it doesn't work out and they get to
dictate where your money and property goes,
so why don't you do it?
Because I love her.
She's an awesome person and it makes her feel better and I don't give a shit.
We have children together and I'm not going anywhere.
So I actually love being married to her.
I love her as a human being.
She's a great person,
but the whole involving the legal system part of it,
it's so dumb.
It's just so ridiculously dumb.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
And I,
I understand completely the need for child support and for some folks needed to
be written in stone what they have to pay and things along those lines.
But you know,
I'm not that person and I,
I don't,
I don't think that I need to be regulated,
you know,
if I've done nothing wrong,
I don't think I need to be signed up to some system to prove that a relationship
that I'm in is valuable to me.
It just,
it seems stupid.
It's almost seems like it's,
if you,
if you trust someone,
it's like,
I do trust you.
I'm going to need that shit on paper.
It's like,
I wonder,
since we're assertive male and more positions of power,
maybe marriage often is to more protect the woman.
Oh,
maybe.
I mean,
I,
I certainly think that there's something to that,
you know,
a woman wants to feel more secure.
I've heard women say that.
I've heard women,
um,
complete,
like being completely outside of them,
eavesdropping in on a conversation and a women were talking about,
you know,
I felt like much more secure in the marriage once or in the relationship once we
were married.
It doesn't make any sense,
but we were together for 10 years,
but once we got married that I felt like it was real and then I could relax.
I had that part of my,
you know,
but that's their own social hangup,
you know?
I think it's just some,
did Sandra Bullock movie shit any different after you got married?
Absolutely not.
I felt like a,
I did something that,
I always thought it was ridiculous.
Well,
you know,
it's like you,
the idea behind it of,
of committing to a person and then giving your all to a person,
that's all beautiful.
The,
the,
the real problem with anything where it's two people is who knows what those two
people are going to be like five years from now,
who knows what they're gonna be like 10 years from now.
And I've seen it and it's ugly.
I've seen people that got along great and then the one person took a left,
the other person took a right and they're stuck in the same house together and
they don't like each other anymore.
And it gets really gross.
And then when they have to separate,
I've seen what happens when they use the legal system against each other.
I mean,
I wrote a whole bit about it because I saw my friend who had to pay for his
wife's lawyer.
He was,
they were going to war and he had to pay for the enemy's general.
Right.
I think it's ridiculous.
I think the idea that if you,
uh,
you know,
if you're taking care of the woman,
you should pay some form of alimony.
Yeah,
definitely the child support.
Yes,
definitely.
You know,
you split property that you got when you were together.
I'm for that,
I'm for all that,
what I'm not for is this gross system where the lawyers play off of each other
and try to stretch things out because that's how they make the most money where
they asked for outrageous amounts so that you come back with like a little bit
less and it becomes this mad hustle.
And like I said,
I am in no way saying that I'm not,
I'm not pro relationship,
but I've watched someone's life fall apart because of a bad divorce.
Whereas if they just broke up,
it would be cool.
But she dragged him through the mud legally for like a year and a half,
two years,
emptied his bank account and it was horrific,
like targeted him.
And that can happen you,
when you're legally attached to someone,
it just,
whereas you could be like,
okay,
we're broken up.
Right.
Well,
I don't want to be with you anymore.
You don't want to be with me anymore.
So we'll just go our separate ways.
No.
Well or if you had the lord,
that's what was even squirrelier.
There's not even any kids involved.
So why do you have to pay for this person
when you described that somebody takes left,
the other person takes the right.
Yeah.
I think that when we started tying to think about Mtma for couples therapy,
cause that's one of the main people reason people use it is for relationships.
And there's um,
but not all relationships should stay together.
So trying to do a study,
a scientific study of,
of MDA with couples.
If you decide that your success is how many of them stay married,
that's not necessarily the smartest thing to do.
So what we felt was that it would be,
if they make a mutual decision and whatever that decision happens to be,
if it can be,
they stayed together,
they split up.
If there's some kind of mutuality about it.
If the MTMA helps them to listen to each other and to communicate and they can
make a mutual decision,
that would be considered a success.
But we haven't gone forward with that research because politically having a
difficult relationship is not a disease and we need to work in a disease context
so that we can get prescription approval to have legal access in a medical
context.
So you,
that's a real issue.
You know that was the issue with Modafinil.
Do you know what that is?
The,
that's one of my whole vigil use agile.
I'm using that right now.
I am.
I might as well.
That's that shit that I've given you.
This stuff keeps you awake.
Yes.
Well,
Tim Ferris,
who I respect very highly,
I had a very interesting point about it.
He said,
I don't believe there's any biological free lunch and that's why he doesn't,
he didn't even put it in the four hour,
whatever for our body because he was worried that people would just start
chewing them like candy.
Well,
I happened to know somebody that uses it for narcolepsy.
He uses a twice a day for about,
uh,
you know,
that's what I'm here to say.
The reason why it's prescribed for narcolepsy has,
because they initially created it for performance enhancing purposes and then
the government's like,
um,
you can't just like say I want my brain to work better.
Like you have to have a disease so they go narcolepsy and that's how it got
approved.
Right.
But it was probably,
it works for narcolepsy.
Okay.
And I got to use it.
People falling asleep all the time.
They're conking out with this stuff.
Does it keep you awake?
Yeah,
but it doesn't,
it's pretty transparent.
It doesn't add a lot of other things.
So it's very weird.
The military is actually shifting towards,
towards it,
away from speed and amphetamines.
Oh,
that's smart.
Yeah.
Speed fucks you up and makes you do shitty things and the next you make terrible
decisions.
Poor decision making capabilities.
And that's worse than alcohol and a lot of ways.
Yeah.
And it's a Modafinil is also for jet lag,
for shift work.
And,
uh,
you know,
the only reason I took it tonight is because I was caught in the gay pride
parade for Francisco couldn't get out of town.
They got you.
And so I just wanted to,
um,
how easy is it to get prescribed something like that?
Because as an example,
I,
I had just got off cigarettes.
I wake up,
you know,
I could barely get out of bed.
Whole Day is
just like I can,
I just lay back down.
I take one fourth of a,
an Adderall and 20 minutes later I'm just like,
how much work can I do?
And I can,
oh my gosh,
my brain's like,
that's a lie.
And it's working.
That's,
but that's a completely different sort of experience.
But for something like,
like that,
it's,
it's also given to people that have like weird shifts,
you know,
jobs,
entertainers and stuff.
You know,
a lot of times I'm talking too much.
I can get your prescription.
Oh,
okay.
You go to a doctor tell you,
don't worry.
I got a doctor.
Okay.
Jesus.
No,
my main person I guess.
Is it,
is it something that's hard to know?
I know people who've done it.
Good.
A doctor.
I'm not feeling so good.
I'm sleepy.
I think
this is something called new vigil.
I think maybe that'll help me.
Boom,
Bang,
boom.
Shut.
Bam.
You're out the door with description.
We're trying to give out prescriptions,
man.
Doctors are trying to give you prescriptions.
Do you know that?
You want to hear something fucking crazy.
There was something in Montana the,
they recently released where Montana has x amount of people living in it.
One fourth of them around oxycontin's
no,
fucking crazy.
That is,
I need to verify that because someone told me that today.
Uh,
oxycontin's
I guess I just never tried to go get prescription medicine ever.
Well
I think there's a time when,
uh,
if it's,
um,
possibly helpful that it can be okay to do it.
I think I prefer trying to do things on my own without it.
And then only if it's,
um,
beyond my capabilities or something that I think enhances it.
So I think the,
uh,
the idea of a jet lag shift,
you doctors do want you to have a,
um,
relationship to what it was approved for.
But around 40% of the prescriptions in America are called off label.
We're doctors prescribe it for things that it's not been approved for.
Oh.
And that cannot be stopped.
That's not bad.
What's some of the things that this drug is used off label,
I guess?
Well,
I think it's a
off label.
People are just taking it for performance enhancing substance reasons.
That's why they're doing it.
That's the big reason that I always here.
And the big diseases narcotic.
Yeah.
And the concern is that,
um,
you know,
if people have performance enhancing drugs,
but they're willing to hurt themselves in order to do it because there's no free
lunch.
But with modafinil there,
there are ranges of use of certain drugs where it doesn't seem like there are
harmful constant.
Well,
it Montana,
a gazette,
the billings gazette is the one that printed this.
It's,
it is one out of four that's unfucking believable.
Montana has just under a million residents.
One out of four have an oxycontin prescription.
It's incredible.
Huh?
Is that pain?
I wonder how they,
listen.
I have,
I've gone in for operations and they gave me a all kinds of shit that I didn't
tank,
but they'll,
they'll give you whatever you need for pain.
Even did you tell him it's nothing I went into to get a deviated septum and uh,
they,
it's kind of uncomfortable thing,
stuff your nose and they crack it and break it and widen it.
I had a really fucked up septum and it was kind of,
I literally,
my nose was useless for most of my life until I had this operation.
But my doctor gave me like two different kinds of pain killers and I,
and I was like,
this doesn't even hurt though.
He's like,
well it's going to probably tonight,
tonight you're probably going to be in significant pain.
Never came.
It was like,
it was weird.
I had this stuffed,
stuffed up my nose,
but there was no pain.
But meanwhile,
if you're a person is easily addictive and you take one of those and you go,
God damn it,
I can't sleep.
And then you take two more of those.
And the next thing I know,
you're going to another doctor and telling me you're in pain.
You get a second prescription and you're off to the races.
Yeah.
We had one of the veterans and our,
uh,
PTSD study,
um,
took one dose,
dropped out of the study and under the influence of this medium dose of Mtma,
um,
he started feeling that he was taking pain meds,
not just for the pain,
but he was kind of getting addicted,
depended on them and he didn't want to do that anymore.
We're war wounds,
things like that.
And so he decided that he didn't need the pain meds anymore and he also felt
like he had come to terms with the issues that had caused him to be suffering
from post traumatic stress disorder,
that he accepted these things and that he could go forward without a PTSD.
And so he dropped out of the study,
but we said,
we want to ask you at two months,
in 12 months,
our followups,
how you're doing.
And his PTSD was still gone after a year.
That's amazing.
The PTSD,
um,
use,
uh,
the use of Mtma for PTSD is a,
one of the ones that was discussed recently by this,
a soldier who wrote this very eloquent letter and then committed suicide when he
was talking about the Dea [inaudible] letter on the airplane here.
Yeah,
I assumed that it was,
when he was talking about,
it's a big,
big issue with,
uh,
with veterans.
I assumed he was talking about marijuana,
what can I do as well?
But I thought it was Mtma probably both,
but the MDM main one has been discussed a lot by friends that I have that have
been in the military.
They know it helps and they want to know about it.
You know,
I heard it's the one where you hear a lot of people going through very traumatic
things and then they get over it.
They're okay,
they understand it and accept it and that's it.
Yeah,
they've heard about it.
Anyway,
we had a meeting in the Pentagon where we are trying to get formal cooperation
and they expressed that their biggest fear was that if they were to cooperate on
an MDA study,
that the word would get out Moreso than before.
And that a lot of people who were in the military,
who only a small number of them will get into clinical studies,
that they would go out on their own and get stuff that was impure or not in s or
pure but not in a safe place and that there that would cause more harm.
And they said that shouldn't stop the research,
but that that was the concern and what we're thinking of saying it,
what would we did say is that the word is getting out and we've had articles in
Stars and Stripes and the Marine Corps times and military.com about the results
of our study.
I think they owed to the soldiers.
And I think that if they wanted to start a Kickstarter to have MTMA clinics pop
up with a legitimate stuff,
government approved and tested all throughout the country,
it would,
it could be user funded.
We are going to do that with the Indiegogo.
Kickstarter doesn't take medical shows but Indeigogo does and we are going to
try to do it to crowdsource a support for the study with veterans,
firefighters and police officers.
Great idea.
The thing about the psychedelics so that people understand what we're really
talking about with the psychedelic Madison is it's only used a few times.
It's not like the drugs that we were talking about that people get prescribed
every day or several times a day.
It's only part of a psychotherapeutic process with more non drug psychotherapy
sessions and what they can integrate from it.
So our three and a half month program for Ptsd,
uh,
treatment includes only three days of Mtma.
I think people need to understand that all these things are tools that have been
denied us.
And uh,
that deal,
I used to joke about it that like marijuana is like a hammer.
You know,
you could,
you could hammer nails with it or you could just hit yourself with a dick if
you're fucking crazy,
right?
Like just cause you have a tool doesn't mean you're going to use it properly.
And when you smoke too much pot and freak out and when you,
you know,
take acid and jump off a roof.
Yes you've done it improperly,
but you're dealing with this incredibly complex thing that is really not being
explained to the general public.
The dabbling in psychedelics is all sort of done with anecdotal evidence passed
on by friends or books that you've read or all the,
all these,
you know and it's unnecessary at this point.
We have enough information.
There's enough data.
There's enough online@maps.org
yeah,
add mass that are we,
we are doing drug development in the open.
We publish our protocols,
we publish our data,
we publish all of our timelines of ours,
relationships with regulatory.
We publish our review of the literature.
We have a treatment manual that describes what the therapy component is that
they are with our adherence criteria.
We're trying to make the all of it publicly available and at the same time
that's the pressure that's coming on the pharmaceutical companies actually to
release more of their data.
But the important thing is that the DEA is not stopping MTMA research.
The FDA is not stopping.
We are able to do psychedelic research in the United States and most countries
of the world where we want to.
We have studies right now in Israel,
Switzerland,
Canada,
and we've done,
I began research in Mexico and New Zealand,
I wasco research in Canada,
so that the only thing that's really politically blocked right now is marijuana
research.
It's hilarious.
It's shocking,
but it's true.
You're getting all this research done and this is,
this is very new,
like two decades ago,
this was not possible.
It was impossible.
And when did it start being possible?
Well,
actually what happened was,
and I did my dissertation at the Harvard Kennedy School of Government,
I got my master's and phd there,
and the part of my dissertation was on how this happened.
Who at the FDA change things and was it other places as well?
Was it a social consensus?
And it turns out that in the late 1980s there was a lot of,
particularly Reagan had been before pro business.
There was a lot of concern that the FDA was too slow evaluating drugs,
that they were mostly trying to block risks and they didn't care that much about
treating illness.
And so the FDA set up this group called the pilot drug evaluation staff,
which was that they would pilot drug evaluation methods to try to speed up the
drug review process.
And this group needed drugs to actually work with.
And so they looked around the other pro parts of the FDA and they kind of
cobbled together different kinds of drugs and they looked at the people that had
control over scheduled drugs and marijuana,
all the psychedelics,
and they had been suppressing things for decades and they said,
sure,
we'll give this up.
And so this new branch came,
they didn't,
but they also were more science over politics.
So starting in 1990 the first study was approved with Dmt by Rick Strassman.
And we had tried for five studies before for years before with the Mtma all
rejected.
But once this new team got into place,
uh,
then they had to review our study Mtma for cancer patients with anxiety.
And there was a 1992 advisory committee meeting to determine whether the FDA
would go forward with psychedelic research and they did it bureaucratically in a
brilliant way.
They had the DEA there,
they had the uh,
office of National Drug Control Policy.
They had the national institute on Drug Abuse.
They had representatives from all of these branches and they proposed an idea
and their idea was that the regulations that they put on the major drugs for the
pharmaceutical industries that the risks of the medical use of psychedelics and
marijuana,
we're no different.
And so they would treat these drugs as if they were drugs being developed by the
pharmaceutical industry.
And the same procedures would be fine.
And the Dea,
Nita,
the drugs,
ours office,
they all thought,
man you put it in there,
they'll,
it'll never get out again because who can act like the pharmaceutical companies.
And so they all signed off and FDA got this policy in 1992 and then they
approved our first study with Mtma,
which was a safety study.
And then they started approving studies with psilocybin and then expanding our
MD may studies into patient populations.
So there's a 20 year history now and a lot of track record and data and now we
have data on the benefits side,
not just on the risk side so that we can talk about balancing before people
could say there are no benefits,
there's these risks,
therefore nothing's permitted.
So the dynamics have completely changed and we've demonstrated so far,
over 800 people have taken Mtma and clinical research all over the world.
And you know,
nobody's gone.
Nobody's had a serious adverse event that left them harmful.
Nobody has become addicts as far as we know to Mtma.
Nobody went crazy.
So we've demonstrated there are safe places.
Our study with LSD and Switzerland for people who are dying was 12 people and 11
of them had never done LSD before.
So it's not,
we're trying to show that it can be brought to people who are not from this
culture,
not used to this,
but it can be helpful to them in a controlled setting with supportive therapists
and with a lot of integration and preparation work.
And people were aware of a other studies like the Johns Hopkins study on
Psilocybin now that's gotten a lot of steam because,
uh,
these people many years later experienced great personality benefits that stuck
with them.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
the study of psilocybin and people who were spiritually inclined to see if they
could have a spiritual experience that actually there was the classic study that
that's modeled on was called the Good Friday experiment and it was done in 1962
and it was one of the best things that Timothy leary ever dead.
And I ended up doing a 25 year followup to,
at tracking these people down.
But basically in 1962,
lots of people thought that psychedelics had some genuine spiritual potential.
And Martin Luther King was getting a phd at Boston University and his mentor
there was Reverend Howard Thurman.
This dynamic black minister who's just fantastic,
and he agreed to have Timothy leary and Ram Das and others,
20 people and 10 guides come into their church on Good Friday and do an
experiment.
And these were all students from Andover Newton theological seminary and half of
them,
they all got pills,
half were psilocybin,
30 milligrams,
which is pretty strong.
And the other half was nicotinic acid,
which gives you this hot flush and it acts quicker.
So that was going to be there double blind.
And then they went through the Good Friday service and Walter Pankey who did the
study,
was a doctor or a minister and getting a phd at Harvard.
And he had spent a year going through the world's mystical literature to develop
a questionnaire for what the mystical experience was.
And he extracted all specific mentions of,
you know,
Jesus or Moses or it's just more of this abstract,
what is a mystical experience and administered this questionnaire.
And nine out of the 20 people had either a partial or a full mystical experience
and eight out of those nine had the psilocybin.
And so the conclusion was that for people who are religiously inclined in a
religious setting,
you can have a psychedelic drugs.
Psilocybin does precipitate what seems to be a genuine mystical experience,
not a hallucination,
but in the mystical literature,
the real test is called the fruits test is what does it you bring back,
what are the fruits of this experience?
And that only comes with time.
And Mulder Pankey who did the study died from a scuba diving diving accident in
1971 and so he would have done this,
but in the middle eighties when I was getting my undergraduate degree,
I decided to track these people down for my senior thesis at New College of
Florida,
which is this experimental school.
And my father was really helpful.
My mother was too.
I identified 19 out of the 20 and was able to interview 16 of them.
And what I found was that the people who had the placebo,
most of them didn't remember it that vividly,
but the people who had the silicide bun had very vivid memories of parts of it.
And at the same time they said that they considered it to be a genuine
experience that had non drug mystical experiences since they preferred the
non-drug mystical experiences cause they were more uniformly positive.
They lost their fear of death and they felt more focused on the here and now and
on social justice cause they had this unit of experience that helped them
identify with the planet,
with the people,
with not so much that all the divisions that divide us,
they saw deeper unity.
And so they were more social justice minded and activists.
And I think that's a little bit of a key to the 60s as psychedelics go.
Right.
They inspire people to try to make a better world and we can do that.
Not In an oppositional way,
but we can do it with in the heart of the culture.
And that's the challenge that we face.
It's really interesting that you said that what they had was a real religious
experience or real mystical experience.
Um,
one of the things has been on my mind,
uh,
over the last few months when it comes to psychedelic parents is that when
people want to tell you,
oh,
you're just,
something is going on,
your imagination,
you create,
your visual Cortex is getting stimulated by this drug and it's creating a bunch
of hallucinations.
It could be that,
but it also could be something else.
It could be you are experiencing some divine state of consciousness.
You are in contact with some other form of intelligence and either it's a
hallucination or it's this other real experience.
But either way you have the exact same experience.
Whether you really went to a place and talked to super spiritual,
highly intelligent beings,
or you imagined you did,
you're still having the exact same experience.
And it's incredibly vivid.
Yeah.
That's the one of the weirdest aspects about any sort of psychedelic experiences
that they're almost more real than reality itself.
And I think because that it's even more important that we keep our critical
faculties in a way because we are always a filter and our culture,
how are,
so I don't think we're ever seeing absolute reality or the truth.
And I think that's where you get in danger where people think,
I,
you know,
God spoke to me,
God said this or I know this for sure because there is our filter that we're
seeing it through.
But you try to see as much as you can.
But I think we have to be aware that,
uh,
and be cautious and see how it works in life.
So under LSD therapy and Mtma therapy would tell people don't make decisions
while you're doing the therapy,
you know,
wait for a couple of weeks after or you know,
at least under the influence is for exploring,
not for deciding.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Although some things do get changed
cause sometimes though you have,
yeah,
you have like a really obvious reaction where,
you know,
you're very aware that,
okay this is,
this is what needs to be done and I need to do this right away.
Yeah.
But it does happen.
And I think one of the more vivid examples for me was when I was sitting for
someone who is doing Mtma,
he was a physician.
And during the experience,
his arm became paralyzed,
completely paralyzed and stop working.
And we were like,
it's not permanent and it's,
it's psychosomatic.
You don't really need to,
you know,
we don't need to take you to the hospital.
And he was a doctor and his arm was paralyzed.
And over time he told this story that lasted a couple of hours.
But the story was that he as was with his mother and his siblings at the bedside
of their father who was dying and all of this life support.
And they had this discussion about whether they should pull the plug or not.
Um,
and because he was the doctor and they decided that they would,
and so he actually pulled the plug in.
The complicating thing was that he hated his father and he wasn't really sure it
was this his anger at his dad or was this what his mother really wanted.
So as he explored this emotionally complex issue and realized he really didn't
kill his dad,
he did what his mother and his siblings were saying.
It was humane.
The feelings started coming back to his arm.
Wow.
So that was the arm that pulled the plug?
Yeah.
Is there a real plug that actually I thought was can be done,
but you know there depends on it.
I don't know.
Good,
good for her because like pulling the plug is the expression.
But what a fucking stupid if life support systems were really like you just go
back there and unplug it.
That's how they shot him on.
Well we never,
we don't want to kill people so we don't have an off button.
So you have to just pull the plug.
Like really silly expression is true today.
You said something that I thought was really interesting too where you said that
in the 1960s you don't think people were ready for it.
I think a lot of people were,
I think that the culture wasn't,
and I think even if you read the
electrical aid acid test,
you know there there's ways in which people are damaged and left behind and
that's something where I felt they weren't quite ready for that.
Isn't that the case?
Always.
Just with life in general,
there's always going to be people that are damaged and left behind.
Well I think one of the beautiful things about the marines and the military is
that they don't leave anybody behind.
And I think that the site that we should adopt that should be the psychedelic
marines in a way,
don't leave anybody behind.
That's really good advice.
Except there's some really annoying people out there and if you get hooked up
with them and you know,
for whatever reason,
they can't carry their own weight psychically,
psychologically,
emotionally,
they're really fucking meeting.
If certain point Tom,
you need to cut,
need to cut ties,
can't fix the whole world.
I think that's really can't,
you know,
you can't and you to tell people that they can is crazy talk right?
You,
there's some people that are just broken animals,
you can't fix them.
Um,
unfortunately they are not you and it's not me,
but we both know people who say,
you know what,
if you had like if there was a show,
like a one of those fixed me up shows,
you know they have those like home improvement shows or weight loss shows.
If you had a guy who was just a complete fucking mess and they said,
just Rick Doblin,
this is your assignment for this show,
you're going to take this guy and elevate his consciousness and,
and just make them a much better person because he could do it with a complete
idiot.
Well I think the beauty of it is that people have to do part of it themselves
and if they're,
and they own it and that's where they become empowered and if they want to fix
them without them taking the courage and maybe there's ways you can help them
through drugs or through therapeutic alliance to have that path in mind.
Right?
They have to be willing to take certain kinds of steps forward.
And so that I think that is the beauty that we can't heal everybody,
that they have to heal themselves.
I think there's also a big danger as a human being in almost embracing the fact
that you're not going to improve because it takes away all the pressure of
trying to improve all the self examination.
As soon as you just say,
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
I don't give a fuck.
Do you really not give a fuck?
Or do you,
is that you're psychic shield to keep you from examining all the holes in your
life,
the game?
Cause that's more likely the case.
Well we talked about the uh,
army veteran that committed suicide,
who wrote that letter.
And one part of that letter was that he had felt like he would never get better.
Yeah.
And I just kept thinking if he could have had an Mtma experience,
would he still have been able to find,
uh,
some hope and a reason to live or would he still have committed suicide?
And those are the questions.
There's,
he,
he talked about 22 veterans a day are committing suicide.
He was dealing with physical pain as well.
I think there was a,
a bunch of different things and that's where he was upset at.
The Dea I think also
add,
uh,
pain meds and how they regulated pain meds.
So I think the MTMA actually in combination with morphine,
it's been used in dying people,
um,
enhances the pain control.
So MTMA has pain relieving qualities and when you combine it with morphine,
when people are,
you know,
in hospice settings,
things like that,
that you have better pain control and you don't need as much morphine and you
start waking people up so that they're not tranquilized out and you open their
hearts so that people can have these beautiful,
beautiful,
pretty much pain free experiences.
There's a woman that wrote a book,
uh,
honor thy daughter about her daughter who died in the early thirties from cancer
and how she had gone through a series of psychedelic therapy sessions as she was
dying with,
um,
Mtma and mushrooms,
Lsd,
MD may combination,
but that it really enriched her daughter's life and she felt she needed to write
a book about,
it's to let people know.
So I think that the use of these drugs,
when people are in pain,
it's not just mental pain.
There's a whole link between mental pain and physical pain and Mtma actually
does help in this kind of,
I see psychedelic medicine,
psychedelic hospice will be pretty common,
I think 2030 years from now.
And we'll look back and think that,
you know,
it made sense 50 years ago.
Oh,
it absolutely does.
I mean,
I think that's one of the best uses for them to give people like a,
I remember Larry Hagman who died a,
was on CNN and uh,
died recently.
Great Guy.
Uh,
I never got to meet him,
but I really loved his interviews.
He was so candid and just warm and friendly.
And he was talking about the importance of a,
an acid trip to the,
had that where it took away his fear of dying.
Yeah,
it was a joy.
Paccar and CNN.
That was fantastic.
It was fantastic interview.
It really was because he wasn't saying it like he was a Kook.
He was just,
is explaining what it did and why I did that.
And you believe them,
you know,
you really did believe him.
Yeah.
I spent years trying to meet him because I knew that he had done LSD therapy in
the 60s.
And he wrote about it in his autobiography.
And My mother in law actually sent me this message saying,
Larry Hagman has done LSD.
So then I started trying to find them and eventually I did meet him and we got
to be friends and he was a donor to maps and he wrote this,
um,
he helped us in a lot,
a lot of different ways,
and he was so human that he would be from Jr and known all over the world.
But when you were with him,
he just was present,
present,
and,
and he wasn't,
you know,
ego inflated.
And he was just a really nice person.
And,
um,
I felt that,
that he had this idealism and this joy from his whole life,
but he also really valued his psychedelic experiences,
his experiences with Mtma,
it's experiences with marijuana.
And it was kind of ironic that someone who was so valued by the culture,
um,
couldn't be open about that,
that he had to keep that hidden.
Well,
he did for a long time until,
until he wrote that book.
Yeah.
The Joy Bihar experience.
But I think also it's like the,
um,
the atmosphere for an actor.
Actors get picked for things.
And if you're very controversial,
I mean,
for every Charlie Sheen,
and of course we're dealing with 2013 were Charlie.
She can get away with being,
it's crazy.
Coke snorting whoremonger and like he just wears it and owns it.
For that to be a thing 20 years ago for an actor,
it could be a career killer.
Yeah.
And when he was doing Dallas,
I mean,
the,
the consciousness of the public's opinion on,
on psychedelics was very much different than it is today.
Yeah.
Well,
he was,
um,
in Dallas when Mtma first became a party drug and it was used at the stark club
of which there's a documentary that sort of the explosion of MDA,
the transformation from MDA as a secret quiet,
um,
therapeutic drug used underground isn't quite right cause it was still legal,
but it was used in a quiet way for fear that if it became known it would become
illegal.
And then in Dallas it started being used and distributed by different people in
nightclub settings and go to Dallas was the place,
right?
Dallas was the place and there's a documentary about the star club and there's
interviews with Larry Hagman in there.
And what he's talking about is this a discussion he had with one of the,
um,
police officers in Dallas and they were saying that Larry had caused them to
lose lots and lots of money.
And he's like,
well,
what do you mean I cause you to lose lots and lots of money?
He said,
well,
after MD may became illegal,
we were going to bust the star club and we had this whole tactical team and
everything was set to go.
And then you and some friends came in.
It's a party.
They're not necessarily to take MTMA and so we didn't want to bust Larry Hagman
from Dallas.
That's a land.
So we had to call off the bus and then come back and do it another time.
One more time.
More and more rather evidence at times have changed because today there'd be
psyched to bus Larry Hagman,
you know,
if was like some dude like that,
like don't make it Larry Hagman making,
I know some other female star,
he didn't necessarily have anything that they could bust him on,
but he was so nice.
He led us to auction off a dinner with him,
uh,
as a donation to maps and this couple,
and also Andy,
Andy Weil did that too.
So we had a dinner,
but that,
the deal they made is I had to come a long Ah,
and I was like,
that would be great to do that.
Why would a great dinner.
Yeah.
Who'd you guys eat dinner with?
This group,
this family from Canada.
And they,
they were just ordinary people,
but they had one of them.
The woman had struggled with cancer had they were,
um,
just love Dallas and loved I dream of Jeannie and hold.
That's right.
He was on I dream of Jeannie.
Yeah.
And we had such a nice time at the dinner.
They also,
the dinner with Andy Weil,
who was he?
The boss on I Janie,
Janie.
And now he was the astronauts.
That's true.
It's the other guy.
He was the main character.
Very in love with Barbara Eden.
That's right.
Yeah.
I always get them confused with bewitched.
I get,
I dream of Jeannie and bewitched confused there.
There he is.
Wow.
B,
which was the one where they had a different dude,
like they killed off the dude and brought in the same,
yes.
Yes.
That was same name,
different guy.
I think now that Larry is the gun,
I can share that.
Um,
he had a bond that was made like the bottle that she lived in.
Oh,
that'd be worth a long weekend.
And we got to smoke pot together in this genie genie bottle and he said that
somebody had talked to him about marketing it and making lots of them and he
said,
no,
he didn't want to have that done.
Yeah,
that's too bad.
We're going to make it now.
But sorry.
But then the family,
he was so nice with this family and just,
and also with me just treat us as like,
you know,
part of his family.
We had dinners kitchen that when it came time for the dinner with Andy,
while that the family invited Larry and he came with a friend of his to help
them travel and we ended up just a few months before he died,
um,
going up and see planes and stuff onto this island where Andy Weil lives and
having this really wonderful experience.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I think guys like him that do those sorts of interviews,
that's a really,
really important thing because the public's perception of people who do LSD is
almost entirely limited to fuck ups and you know,
and crazy people and wild people.
Or they used to do acid.
Oh,
this guy used to do acid,
he did acid back off his rocker.
You never hear about it.
Positive drug experience like that from a very respected person.
Right.
And that's what we need is the coming out of loads of people like that who are
retiring baby boomers.
So I think time is on our side.
There's all these people who are more fearless because they're not worried about
what they tell their kids or they're not worried about their jobs.
They've made a reputation and they can talk like Steve Jobs.
I had a wonderful opportunity,
I tried for years and finally managed to have a half hour conversation with him
about our LSD study.
Did he give you like a half an hour on an iPhone and go,
ready press star.
Is it facetime?
Cause Start 29,
28 before I had an iPhone.
And uh,
you didn't have an iPhone when you met him.
How dare you.
And I didn't meet him.
It was just on the fun.
And um,
at the end of it he said,
you know,
send me a proposal.
But um,
I didn't never heard back.
He wasn't known for being philanthropic,
but I had gotten a letter from Albert Hoffman to him,
um,
on his,
after it 102nd birthday.
Wow.
And,
um,
I'll say acid lives to be one or
two.
And he was married for over 70 years.
The same person.
Um,
he led,
I mean,
Albert Hoffman to pivot just for a second was such a perfect example.
We're so fortunate that he's the one that invented LSD because he was
everything.
What I'm trying to talk about in terms of integrating,
he was a big successful chemist for a major pharmaceutical company.
Sandoz.
He made drugs.
It's sold hundreds of millions of dollars.
He lived in more or less than the same place.
He had a wife for over 70 years.
He had children,
very normal,
very normal guy with his wife up pink dragon.
Um,
we,
I was fortunately able to be with the Albert when they tried to MDA for the
first time.
How old was in the drive?
It's they soon as 80s
or late seventies.
Um,
and so what he said was,
um,
ah,
finally something I can do with my wife because she had had kind of a scary
experience with Lsd.
A lot of people have,
man.
Yeah.
Have you done any tests with like candy flipping,
like mixing,
you know,
acid?
Well,
I believe that that actually has incredible therapeutic potential.
Um,
however we've not actually tested it because in the scientific world you want
just one variable if possible.
And so to combine LSD and Mtma,
which drug are we trying to make a medicine and are always going to combine
them,
but I honestly,
it becomes legal.
That would be I think maybe even before,
well,
that's the question.
You know,
it maybe it's 10 years before these drugs can become medicalized legal in a
medical way.
I think that that long,
um,
I,
you really think it could be sooner.
I think that's possible now more than ever.
There's a certain track of data that you have to produce a certain set of
requirements that were on the track of doing.
But it looks to me like it's eight to 10 years,
even if it was certainly,
no.
Well,
I've always been wrong.
And I've always underestimated how long it takes you more.
We were talking about earlier
gay rights.
I think they equate,
cause when I was a kid,
I remember I was living in San Francisco,
uh,
from seven til 11.
And uh,
it was around a lot of gay people and uh,
it was completely normal because that was just what I was around.
And then when I moved to Florida,
when I was 11,
my friend candy is Candido is or Cuban kid,
his dad was really pissed off with the newspaper,
slams it down and he was,
he was mad that,
uh,
the,
the fags wanted to get married.
That's what he kept saying,
I believe this shit,
these fags want to get married.
And then I remember I was like 11.
I was like,
what?
Why do you care?
Like,
well,
you're a grown man.
Like this is what,
how stupid some grown manner.
And I was like,
that's a weird argument.
Like that's a strange thing.
So that was,
you know,
a long ass time ago.
I'm 45 years old now,
so I was 34 years ago and um,
the,
I know it's not,
yeah,
it is.
Okay.
But it's the idea that that back then it was,
it was really something that people fought against.
It was really a,
a subject of you could,
you could be public about it and not feel like an ignorant asshole.
Whereas today if you say that you're against gay people being married,
like you're nothing but a fool,
right?
You're nothing but a full,
if you,
you,
you honestly think it's either you're crazy with religion and you honestly
thanked that somehow or another,
it's possible to cure person of being gay.
And if they believe in the scripture that's,
you know,
that I can't even talk to you.
That's,
that's a different animal.
But if you're a rational person and you accept the fact that people were born
gang and you,
you have an issue with them marrying their lover,
like you're a crazy person.
Yeah.
I think though that people who are irrational,
they're there.
That's the question.
How do we rationalize the ration?
I think there's a way that they're fearful of something that blocks their
rational thinking and if you can somehow or other help them.
And I think a lot of people who are so anti gay are scared of their own gay
feelings.
It's kind of a cliche,
but I think that's often the case.
But I think what drove me early on into an interest in psychedelics is that I
was so terrified of World War II and the Holocaust and how people can be so
blind or be willing to be so driven by irrational factors that I thought,
what can we do to try to help get to heal that?
Because some people,
you know,
they,
they can be quite powerful and they can,
um,
how do you respond?
And that,
that was the dilemma for me.
And I finally felt that,
um,
growing up with the Vietnam war,
that that was something that now I was being called to fight and I decided to
become a draft resistor.
But I saw the nuclear standoff between the U S in Russia and it just seemed like
the irrational was so powerful.
The demonization of the other.
And the making of the enemy that there was,
I couldn't figure out how to uh,
contribute to breaking through that cycle.
And it finally felt like this,
um,
deep spiritual experience of connection and letting people's fears come up where
they could look at them more.
That that would be for an individual make us more grounded and less likely to be
manipulated are irrational factors.
And if millions of people could have that experience,
which did happen during the 60s,
but if we can expand it,
that maybe there is a basis to go through the crises that we're facing over the
next couple of decades as a species and as globalization and people are bumping
up against each other that it felt like somehow or other the irrational is based
a lot on fear and how can we help people to counter that with love,
with hope or with looking with self acceptance.
And I think that's where the MTMA is so useful that the fear of self criticism
or the fear that Mtma helps people to accept who they are and the LSD and the
silicide bend,
the Iowasca,
the masculine,
the Payoti,
those,
the drugs,
they are challenging in a different way.
And that they do this dissolving of the control mechanisms and dissolving of the
ego and,
and hopefully people can let go and blend and be strengthened from that.
And that's the support that we need to provide to help that to be happening.
And I think,
you know,
just the way that this religious fundamentalism against gay marriage,
I mean,
right now we have a crisis of fundamentalism around the world.
There's a crisis of ideology.
Yeah.
So,
and it's also a crisis of power because once someone gets into a position where
they can espouse their ideology,
you listen to them,
that is power.
And then they use that power to get money,
to manipulate,
to get sex,
to do whatever the fuck they want and not pay taxes.
There's a lot of craziness.
It's almost like in and not pay taxes thing.
It's almost like they're in cahoots.
It's like the government has decided,
look,
it'd probably be beneficial if you guys did a good job and you know,
cult it up the shit out of some people and get them all whacked out on your
ideas to the point where they're complete fundamentalists on your idea.
So how about you not paid taxes?
You know,
how about we help you along there,
you know,
make it even more profitable,
more susceptible to corruption?
Well,
I think that there,
there is that,
um,
way in which the government can be influenced by groups.
Sure.
And I think that's something also that we have to be wary of some mess,
but at the same time we have to work through groups and work through government.
So I think this,
um,
one of the first things we learned at the Kennedy School is there is no,
the government,
it's like your body,
there is no,
your body,
there's all these different organ systems.
They all work in different ways.
So we find out about that when the government goes after itself.
Like when,
when this general Patraeus thing happened,
we found out the CIA and the FBI don't necessarily see eye to eye.
Right.
You know?
And that's where our strategy is built at.
The FDA is putting science over politics while the other forces are trying to
either slow down or black research.
And where it comes with marijuana is that there's a government monopoly on the
supply of marijuana that can be used in federal research.
So even though there is no monopoly on the supply marijuana,
the only kind that's been grown under DEA license is controlled by the national
institute on Drug Abuse.
And it's hilarious.
You want to get to do research to make marijuana into a medicine.
The FDA will give you permission.
We have a permission to do a study with marijuana in 50 veterans for post
traumatic stress disorder.
And our distinction is that the marijuana is more about treating symptoms and
the Mtma is more about curing is getting.
And then you only need Mtma a few times with the marijuana people sort of need
every day.
Yeah.
But we have FDA approval and Nada and the Public Health Service rejected the
protocol and refused to provide the marijuana for us.
And they only can review protocols for marijuana because they've got sitting on
this monopoly and we were 12 years lawsuit and we won and won.
And then we lost in the first circuit court of appeals to break the monopoly.
But that's the core reason why we're not able to make progress with marijuana
research and we are able to make progress with psychedelics.
And are they afraid of with marijuana?
I think they're afraid of the whole drug war collapsing,
that the marijuana is incredibly demonized.
It's widely used most.
There's a lot of people that know that it's not so dangerous.
And I think it's the,
it's a symbol,
it's a symbol of cultural rebellion.
And that's where it was embedded in certain people's minds.
And even though it was made illegal in 37 with the marijuana tax act,
then it was illegal shortly after prohibition ended.
And it was illegal during the depression and mostly it was Mexicans and blacks
that smoked pot.
And so it was a way to repress people who are competing for low wage jobs.
It was a way to block the hemp industry,
various things like that.
But,
but it largely was a minor thread in American history until the 60s and white
suburban people started,
kids started smoking pot and you had this massive explosion of pot and then pot
and LSD got associated with cultural rebellion.
And now all these years later,
you know,
there are many people that smoke pot that are at least out about that.
And it made a lot of contributions.
So I think it's more now about fear of parents for their kids.
It's shifted.
But that's what's driving what's left of the drug war is parents wanting to
protect their kids and also all these vested interests that have the prison
unions and things like that.
The,
but I think that dynamic we're trying to is shifting also.
And so there's a way in which those of us who were interested in enhancing our
lives with these drugs in positive,
responsible ways need to do so.
Need to speak about it,
where possible and need to demonstrate that.
It's not about tearing down the society,
it's strengthened.
It's all of us coming together to face these incredible challenges and we need
all the inspiration and we need all the creativity and we need all the energy
that we can.
So unfortunately for some people they really can't speak out about it because
they get drug tested at work.
That's a big issue.
I mean the,
the,
the idea that something that stays in your body as long as marijuana,
it gets tested.
When the psychoactive,
the,
the time in which your body brings it back to baselines lines less than 24
hours,
right?
I mean is your,
your,
you basically just have traced metabolites.
It stays in your system for a long ass time,
but they're not psychoactive.
So you're at work,
you get it.
You spoke to join on Friday,
you're at work on Monday.
Then like you take a piss test,
you piss positive.
They're penalizing you for something you're doing when you're not at work really
is not going to
affect work.
You can also be arrested for driving under the influence.
Yeah.
From metabolites that you took from pot a week ago.
Right.
It's nonsense.
It's so crazy.
The idea that that,
first of all,
the idea that they treat,
they have some arbitrary level that they test you for and they say,
well this is,
you can't operate a marijuana vehicle vehicle on marijuana if you have this
function or system.
It's been proven.
What tests have you done?
Well,
where's the science behind the national level?
When you look at the science,
the experience,
marijuana smokers are not debilitated by in their driving and there's been a lot
of driving tests that had been done.
And what they show is that when you are drinking alcohol and driving that you
are impaired,
but you don't think you're impaired.
And so you were more reckless that under a marijuana people know that sometimes
their instincts,
their reaction time might be slow.
So you take compensating action.
So people are more careful when they're driving and more aware.
So in driving,
not in simulators,
but when they're out in driving roads and cars that and in simulators to that
marijuana is very
minimally affecting driving and you become paranoid.
So you'd drive a little slower and,
and you react a little slower to,
and really you think you react slower physically?
No,
I mean by that that,
no,
cause I've a lot look at all these basketball players that you know,
tied into it.
It's just,
yeah,
you didn't know about that Jujitsu.
I didn't.
Huge in the Jiu Jitsu community.
Massive snowboarding.
A massive amount of people smoke pot and then go train the,
the,
it's so much.
So they have t shirts rolling all stoned,
rolling stone.
They have all these different,
uh,
I mean it's so common in the janitor world.
Yeah.
I play racquetball and so I can have combined marijuana,
racquetball and train myself to be really quick reacting.
Yeah.
And sometimes I play my best games when I'm stoned and sometimes I don't
give a fuck and it balls,
but I can never tell ahead of time whether it be better or not.
But that's funny.
But I think with driving that,
um,
what I meant by reaction time is that you don't take precipitous action.
So the classic thing is that you're,
I'm going somewhere,
I'm thinking about something I,
I don't turn where I wanted to turn,
but then I just like calm way,
find my way back.
I don't like jerked the wheel.
I do want to clarify though,
that that's you,
you're in a,
you're an intelligent guy and you have your shit together.
Right.
That's true.
I think for most folks it's,
you know,
I don't like driving Tai.
I don't,
I'd rather be sober.
I don't like it.
There's a lot of things that I don't like to do when I'm high.
I don't mind it,
but I want to get pulled over and I'm high and I got to talk my way out of,
you know,
some cop being upset at me for being high,
like two of them telling me how to drive fine.
I'm good.
I don't want to be involved in that situation and I don't,
I think I'm,
I would be kind of a hypocrite if,
uh,
if I said that and like,
or if I,
if I had a problem with some people getting high and driving,
but I know some people were impaired.
There's,
there's,
there's certain people that freak out and they get high.
Even driving when you were impaired.
Yeah.
When you freaking out.
I think even if it's only psychologically,
even if your reflexes are still there,
you're still impaired,
you know,
your
don't drive like that.
Please stop sobriety driving.
I think go hand.
I did have you talked about being high and having to talk to a police officer.
Um,
I was actually going to visit John Lilly and a chemist friend of mine had
separated the isomers of ketamine and I was going to bring that to John who
hadn't tried the different isomers yet.
Um,
this is in Florida and it was way long time ago.
And uh,
I was,
um,
I had a Porsche nine 14,
which is small,
cheap car,
but just says the open top.
And so I was going from Sarasota,
Florida to Miami,
and it was just such a beautiful night and the moon was out and I was stone.
And I thought,
okay,
I'm going to speed.
It's just beautiful.
I'm going to get a ticket,
but it's okay.
And I thought,
okay,
as long as I'm just going to get this ticket.
Well,
why don't I just think about what I could tell the police officer when the
inevitable happens.
So you're thinking about this as you're planning for your ticket as and fire for
it tickets.
What,
what can I tell him about that would somehow or other the bok and I thought the
first thing is don't deny that I'm speeding.
You know,
don't,
don't contradict an I think,
but the main thing I thought is what do we have in common?
You know,
and the only thing I could think of is we're two guys out in the road.
I don't fry lonely guys on a Friday night out in the roads.
And so none of blow this car to get out and took it.
And I'm very,
you know,
the story was that I was on my way to see my girlfriend and I was,
and that was late.
Okay.
And officer,
I am speeding and I'm sorry,
but that's what I was doing.
And so it happened.
I got pulled over,
I told the story and the guy was like,
you know,
I'm going to let you go.
Just tell her that it's from me,
that you owe this for me.
Well,
that's a nice car and get lucky and get a nice cop.
Yeah.
I don't have a many time.
And then with John Lilly,
um,
you know,
one of the isomers is more active than the other.
And so that was interesting,
but I also did get the sense that he was too much into the ketamine and too much
into this other state.
And it,
I started trying to think about how possibly we could help him because he was
such a major contributor in a hero of mine.
And one of the people that was a dolphin trainer that worked with him with some
of his dolphins,
had this sense,
uh,
Roberta Goodman had this sense that,
he was also going down hill.
And so we are,
are arranged to get together
with them to do MD may therapy.
And during that he kind of became very much into his body,
but he had abscesses from where he was shooting himself.
He was in terrible shape.
So he was shooting ketamine.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
In our Moscow.
Really?
Or did you do IB would do it ivy.
Sometimes he would do it.
[inaudible] he would get,
he just was so trying to be out of body and another place that he wasn't taking
care of himself.
Wow.
And he was,
and,
and it was painful to them.
And,
and so he kind of bounced into this awareness of what he was doing.
So he had infections and infections.
Yeah.
He was her.
Wow.
And He,
um,
he didn't want to stay there and deal with it.
And so what we,
we couldn't help him,
you know,
because he didn't want it,
didn't want to deal with it.
Also is probably dealing with the reality of what the king body,
and he was an older man and he probably figured,
you know what,
this,
these states of mind,
I like this better.
You know,
I'll just ride this bitch until the wheels fall off.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that take that approach as well.
Yeah.
And I'll end up to a guy who spent so much time in altered states of
consciousness.
I don't think it's unreasonable to like prefer that.
I think it is.
I think it is because I think when you get this deeper sense about how
life is so precious that that you can have these other states of mind,
but that it should be inculcating compassion,
a sense that you have to contribute to make it a better world.
That this kind of self destructive isn't ultimately a few times,
I mean,
there isn't,
we live,
we die.
I mean,
um,
that this guy is feeling is Bobby giving out on him and he says,
you know what?
I'm just gonna Shoot Ketamine until the boat hits the rocks.
Well,
I think giving makes people happy.
A lot of times people are depressed,
you know,
if they serve or help others.
I even thought about that,
about the vet that,
you know,
if there was some way,
he felt that he was a harm to his family and that he was doing them good by
killing himself.
And I think if only there would've been some soup kitchen or something that he
could have felt that he was contributing,
maybe that would have,
and we kind of addressed that.
Didn't even know he was talking about the all the widows and created and that he
didn't feel like he had the the right to exist.
Right.
But that's psychological material to work through.
That's not necessary.
And I think even that's a hard thing to say.
But you're saying it from coming from someone who was an MDM experiences.
And I think unless somebody has,
they really would,
would listen to this like a straight person.
Not not mean knocked day,
but I mean a square car has never done any drugs.
And Paul,
I've really not been into drugs and I've took some percocets in college.
If that person heard that,
there we go.
What is this guy talking about?
Like if the guy had post traumatic stress
disorder from murdering people and you know,
committing war crimes and he's openly spoke about it in this letter and then
you're telling them he's going to take ecstasy and he's going to,
he's going to be able to work through that.
Like what of,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Yeah,
that's a really good point.
In fact,
people have accused us of like,
you're going to try to help people just forget what they did.
And you can make mindless soldiers who will commit war crimes and then they get
a drug and they feel better and they go back.
And so I think that's a really good point,
your race,
because it's not that people say that was good,
that I can accept that that was good.
They don't reframe what they did into something good,
but they realize that they,
it's done.
If they accept it,
it can give them the chance in the rest of their life to make up for it.
Not that you can in any way,
but it gives you a way to go forward in a positive way.
And I think that if we do this in a marine's,
let's say,
my guess is that it will make them more sensitive about those kind of occasions
where they might be reckless with their machine gun or something that it might
make them more careful.
Um,
I don't know.
These are like unknown questions and it's,
it's really important.
But the process of dealing with post traumatic stress disorder is to more live
in the present,
to let the past inform you,
not to deny it and,
but not to be so oppressed by it and to accept what you've done.
And I think once you accept that there is that evil and all of us that we have
to like those,
you know,
that we all have the capacity under certain circumstances to that,
that you can accept that.
And,
uh,
what we hope is that people then can move forward and recognize that they still
have some life and every day they can make choices and everyday they can try to
be helpful to somebody or we're not.
And I think that's what we're talking about,
the healing.
It doesn't make them look back and say that was okay what I did.
I think we are in a very strange period of,
of,
of human history where we,
we know that we have all these issues.
We know we have massive government corruption.
We know we have massive financial corruption.
We know we have the great majority of people who don't agree with war acts that
are going on,
whether it's drone attacks or what have you.
And we wonder like,
why is our society so far behind?
Why have we achieved so such great technological and military heights,
but yet socially were so fucked up.
And we have all the tools to fix that.
And that's what's really insane.
It's like individuals have found with their own unique situations that through
yoga or through Mtma or through meditation or even some
through religious chanting.
And,
and,
and learning how control of your breath can change states of mine.
People have gone that through jogging.
You were talking about smoking pot and getting high.
I know a lot of people who think things through when they're jogging and let
things go when they're jogging too.
I think there's many,
many,
many pieces that we can use to try to fix this problem.
And they all,
they're all documented.
Like we're not living in the dark ages anymore.
Right.
And I think this is one of the first generations it's been around.
It's experienced that that has that many tools.
And I think you're right on when you talked about how we're overdeveloped
intellectually and underdeveloped emotionally and spiritually.
It's not even that were underdeveloped.
It's just were not developed at all.
You know what I mean?
It's like most people were acting on momentum or imitating their atmosphere.
Yeah.
Well,
were developed some,
we think the primates are pure instincts.
Yeah.
I mean,
as a science society it's pretty crazy.
groups are,
you know,
that,
that's what I thought about,
you know,
Hitler's Jeremy,
that,
that you've got a culture that's insane.
We're not,
we're rights North Korea right now.
They're all programmed and yeah.
So that there's a way in which if you look at our technology,
which is miraculous,
but we,
and we have capacities now to alter the planet with global warming,
but we don't have the emotional and spiritual development to cope with the
technological changes.
And in a way that's been really productive,
this kind of separating out the intellect from religion and morals,
you know,
because religion and morals sort of squashed the intellect and didn't want a
Copernicus and Galileo and just a whole history of things.
But is that really religious or is that just the people claiming to be religious
human beings?
Yeah.
Right.
It's just the ideologies behind these ideas that didn't want to relinquish
power.
Yeah.
Because Albert Einstein talked about how a true science and true religion are
not in opposition,
and that the scientist is also,
you know,
in a state of wonder and spiritual appreciation.
Yeah.
Because people that think that religion is ridiculous or that God is ridiculous,
or the concept of a higher powers with Dojo,
us,
you know what else is ridiculous?
The whole universe itself,
the fact that there's a floating ball quarter,
the size of the earth called the moon,
just floating in space above us.
How?
How heavy is that stupid thing?
It's just floating above us.
Oh,
and without it,
our world would not exist because our temperature would not be regulated enough
that we could live in cold climates and hot climates.
It wouldn't be predictable enough.
We'd be fucked.
I mean,
that's,
that's crazy.
That's way crazier than some guy who built everything through,
you know,
big bang.
That's crazier than anything that religions ever come up with ever.
That the whole universe was smaller
than the head of a pin and then exploded 13 point whatever billion years ago and
created the skies above and everything you said.
Yeah.
Well you said,
is it futile?
You live and you die.
And I think that those moments of wonder or appreciation for just how
miraculous,
mysterious and comprehensible or those moments of love,
that there's a way in which they make life worth it.
I agree.
And I think that there can be a,
I wanna,
I don't wanna use the word religion,
but their kin and then I'm like ideology.
But there could be a way of living the life with wonder and with sharing
knowledge and with just looking into what we have learned rock solid about the
very universe we live in and respecting that and worshiping that.
I mean in a way,
you know,
not like I'm not talking about like a deity but about like,
like a great wonder,
like the great wonder that it really is and there's a benefit to that.
Yeah.
And taking that into the pain I think is being able to take the loving energies
into the places that need healing and that that's where,
so just having a spiritual meditating on top of a mountain top and trying to,
you know,
get off the wheel of suffering and stuff.
That seems like a very egotistical way actually.
And having the sense that while we though some of us are privileged in all
different ways to really be healthy and be wonderful with that and in wonder
without being so threatened that there's a lot of people that aren't and that we
have to
not only feel those moments,
but then try to somehow as Martin Luther King talked about the arc of history,
make some contribution of some way that helps it for others too.
You know what was also ironic,
one of the weird things that's going on with society,
uh,
is that as our technological capabilities increase,
we also fill our skies with light pollution and we can't see the stars.
And one of the best psychedelic experiences I ever had outside of doing a drug
was I went to the Keck observatory and y on the big island.
And we drove through the clouds and as we were driving,
like you wonder if it's going to be a cloudy day eggs and you won't be able to
see anything because it takes a while to get up there.
And I was like,
Damn,
looks like it's cloudy.
But then we drove through the clouds and you realize,
oh,
this thing is so high up there that you actually drive past where the clouds
are.
This is nuts.
And we went up to the observatory and the view is just insane because the big
island is set up for the observatory,
so all the lights that they use for streetlights or a very special type of
diffused lighting that doesn't give light pollution off.
So you have this incredible view of the stars where you see the whole Milky Way,
like a movie,
like,
like those pictures of space and somehow or another,
it's just above us and you're looking at it,
it's,
it's so unbelievably humbling and,
and,
and magical.
I was like,
I was staring into the impossible and I remember being upset that I couldn't see
this every night that's up there all the time.
And,
and not seeing that and just making it this blank screen.
By doing that you sort of like lose,
you'll lose the feel for what's really going on.
Yeah,
we're out of touch with that a lot.
I had this bonding moment with in some ways my opposite.
And my family and I were on a vacation in Israel and we decided to go across the
Sinai desert by car to go see a Cairo and the pyramids.
And we had to work with an Egyptian company and they had people had armed guards
cause it's kind of dangerous now.
And so as we were driving through the Sinai desert,
um,
and it was so dark and the sky was magnificent,
we asked if we could just stop the car and just sort of walk a bit from the
road.
There was hardly any,
virtually no other traffic on the road.
The only thing,
we're military checkpoints every once in a while and we just went out.
And so these,
um,
it was Ramadan too.
And so these Muslims who were with guns to protect us,
uh,
who are Jewish,
we just stood under the stars in the middle of the desert with no light
pollution and just had this shared moment of kind of odd.
The Majesty.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the view of the actual view that we're supposed to see,
I think is really what inspired people throughout history to,
to create the idea of gods and to create this,
I mean the,
the,
the insane view that you get of that,
that just the images of those magical lights in the sky,
millions and billions of them.
Just to see that it's,
it's so humbling and to not see that it's,
it's so dead.
It's sold numb.
Like we don't have an appreciation for the fact that we're in space.
You watch a documentary,
it seems kind of abstract,
but when you're on top of the observatory and you,
you look out and you have that incredible view of the stars,
you go,
oh my God.
Like we are really in space right now.
We are on a big organic spaceship and we're moving thousand miles an hour in a
circle.
Yeah.
It's nuts.
It's,
it's weird to see.
Right.
And what,
what it's done to Stuart brand talked about a lot about the,
with the whole or is cloud the picture of the earth from space?
Yeah.
We're the first generation or two that's ever had that image.
And those astronauts that go up in the space station,
a spatial,
they all talk about the experience.
It's being very transcendent.
You know,
when you take that view of the earth from above and you look down,
you see just the nature of the whole reality of a planet in the solar system,
in a galaxy,
in a universe.
And it's,
it all just sort of falls into place.
You're like,
oh my God.
But when you're down here and you're stuck in traffic and the skies dark,
you don't even think about it,
but you're,
you're on this majestic ride through the heavens.
Instead you're overwhelmed with a Moan,
mundane bullshit of this person in front of you,
not reacting to the green light.
Come on.
And if you can somehow do both,
it's not that.
Yeah.
And that's where I think lily lily got wrong.
You know,
you've got the spiritual part was the more important part.
And it's the balance.
I,
my daughter,
Ellie is in eighth grade and she had to do a project with,
uh,
for national history day and with a couple of her girlfriends,
they did a project on Apollo 11,
which was,
and it turned out that,
um,
the girl that she did it with,
Michael Collins was her grandfather.
He was the one that was on the,
when Armstrong put his foot on the,
and I'm buzz Aldridge that he was the one that stayed in the capsule.
And so they actually got to interview him as part of this and he did talk about
for him what was so amazing both being up there in space and seeing the earth,
but also when he got back and they went around the world and people were
cheering and talking about things,
he said that he thought that people would say,
you know,
look what you Americans did.
And wherever we went,
people said,
look what we did.
Like it was the human race that we went to the moon and people wanted to be part
of that.
And he,
because it was such a space race with Russia,
he started,
we did it.
But he saw,
you know,
we're Americans did it,
but he saw around the world that people said we all collectively did it
well,
the idea of we all collectively are in this thing together,
that we are a global community.
And that's really one of the last saving hopes of humanity.
And I think the Internet has sort of reinforced that idea in a way that never
existed.
I think nationalism,
the idea of nationalism seems so much more preposterous now,
especially nationalism and a war sense.
Nationalism,
it's nothing wrong with being proud of the town you live in.
No,
nothing brought warm with a cheering for the,
you know,
your home basketball team.
There's nothing wrong with any of that.
But what's wrong is when it translates into war.
And I think that this is the first culture that has really sort of openly
embraced a global society.
You know,
I think kids today,
they're far less likely to buy the bullshit when it comes to us against them or
any ideas about,
you know,
what's really going on with geopolitical struggles.
Yeah.
We know the kids in Iran,
like they're just,
they're kids to try and get out of the,
under the thumb of an oppressive government.
What my son Eden,
who is just going to college,
he was playing a halo and you can play multip,
you know,
and he was playing with somebody in a Saudi Arabia.
It's so great.
It's fantastic.
And I think what we see a lot is the rise of fundamentalism.
You know,
the Orthodox Jews are nuts.
The,
some of the Orthodox Christians and Muslims,
all these,
I think because of the forces of globalization,
because it's harder to sustain that we're the one,
right?
Religion,
they're,
they're kind of having to circle their wagons and they become a bit more
extreme.
And so it might look on the surface that things are getting worse.
But I think that's this defensive mechanism where they can barely hold it
together.
And I think it won't end up with homogenous one world religion,
one government.
We'll appreciate those small things about the,
you know,
the local town,
where are you are,
you can appreciate the differences even more when you feel part of the
commonality.
You don't have to be scared of the differences cause there's something deeper
that connects it.
I think there's also a problem that people have in the human beings.
We share chimpanzee Alpha male DNA and we are always looking for leaders.
And Yeah,
the other problem is once someone becomes a leader,
uh,
we see there was with politicians and dictators,
we saw it with the people that that came in after Mubarak in Egypt tried to pass
all these crazy fucking laws that essentially made them dictators.
And then the people were like,
what are you talking about?
Like this is,
this is what we just shed blood for.
Like in you assholes are trying to make yourself immune to prosecution for all
these different things that you could be doing.
Like fuck you.
No,
you can't do that.
And I think seeing that for the first time,
you know,
globally,
even though right now it may be very frustrating for us and it is frustrating
for us because we don't think change is coming quickly.
Enough change that the corresponds with what we know about the world.
I think it is.
If you look at it historically,
if they look back to this time,
I think this will be a time of great turmoil and great change.
It's just that we measure history and he's 20,
30 year bursts.
You know,
and I think the 20 year bursts that we're in right now is just bananas.
Well,
I think as I get older and as I watch my kids grow,
that for me,
10 or 20 years is no longer such a long time.
Right?
It's not.
And I think as you get older,
time speeds up to,
and so it's like those cops that were there so you can,
so you can,
but we're not quite so scared.
Parts are late.
And the um,
the side
of having a 20,
30 year plan or even to recognize as all the spiritual traditions talked about
is that,
uh,
these great things are not accomplishable in one generation or buy one in one
lifetime.
So that we just start the process are we not start it,
but we continue and then we try to pass it on to the next generation.
But I think that there is this,
you know,
intensification and crisis and in that I think eventually the,
um,
the,
the fundamentalists,
we'll need to find more genuine spirituality,
not in this rigidity and hopefully they'll be able to coexist.
There was these demonstrations of millions of in Egypt,
the,
you know,
against the Muslim broaden brotherhood.
This is the first government in Israel that doesn't have the religious orthodox
as part of the governing body,
which is a really healthy thing.
This,
what does it who,
who made that quote history is a race between education and catastrophe.
Who's that?
Who is responsible for that quote?
You know,
I don't know.
That's,
yeah.
I don't remember who it was.
Whoever it was.
They were bad motherfucker,
whoever it was.
But that's a,
that's really what seems to be going on.
Was it hg wells?
Yeah,
that was good.
That there really does seem to be,
well of course it's a,
she was,
the guy was awesome.
Um,
I think that that does seem to be what's going on.
It seems to be also that sometimes it almost feels like people need an
antagonist in order to perform at their very best.
It's almost like we need a rival to inspire us to reach great heights.
Yeah.
And it depends on how you see them.
If they're deeper down your ally,
so that like,
let's say in sports teams,
you know,
you want your opponents to be as good as possible because that will call out the
best in you.
So at some level you want the worthy opponent that you don't have to totally
destroy.
You just are sort of coal valving together.
So I think we do need to test ourselves against,
against others and against our ourselves,
but we don't need to see the other side as the enemy to be destroyed.
And I think,
uh,
I used to play this game,
um,
grew up in Chicago in Winnetka and Lake Michigan and some friends and I would go
in there and we'd play the greatest catch game and each of us guys,
we'd throw a football to somebody else.
It was like half in the water.
And our,
our goal as the thrower was to get it just barely where they could reach it,
where they had to make the spectacular dive and show off to everybody how great
they were and then they would have to do it back.
And so we are sort of helping.
We are,
we are like allies,
but we were pressing each other to,
to do spectacular things.
That's really interesting.
Well that's one of the principles of a,
of Jujitsu and a martial arts is that you really only as good as your training
partners.
Yeah.
Have you trained with really good people,
you become really good and that's you.
You elevate to the level of the competition in the training room.
It's also the same a lot with a standup comedians were inspired by other really
funny standup comedians.
And when you find a particular group of group of talented people in a,
in a town or an area,
oftentimes they'll develop a lot of very talented people around them who we
imitate the fact that you know that there's a high level of the art form and
that area.
So like Austin,
Texas is a good example.
It's like there's always a lot of really good guys there and because there's
always a lot of really good guys there,
there's always a lot of really good guys.
There is a New York city's and other one,
but obviously this much more money involved in places like New York or La and
being good.
So that becomes sort of a factor as,
but are you from
us?
Did you spend time in Austin?
No,
I just have a lot of friends there and I've done a lot of stand up there,
but I just know the local scenes or he's really strong.
So there's a few places in the country as a comedian,
the scene,
the local scenes are very strong.
Denver,
they always have a really strong local scene.
And that's another one that's pure because it's not really attached to Hollywood
and any way it's just pure standup comedy.
And then there's San Francisco,
um,
Boston,
La,
New York,
little bit of Phoenix a little bit,
but it's,
it's a very limited thing.
And you can sometimes one or two great comedians will be in one area.
And then boom,
it'll blossom.
Like,
um,
Houston was Sam Kinison and Bill Hicks.
They were all at this Houston comedy annex and because of them in this one
particular area,
it started to take off.
Yeah.
That's sort of the idea of silicon valley.
Yeah,
sure.
Get a bunch of brilliant people and you get inspired by other brilliant people.
They share ideas.
They,
they,
you know,
they pump each other up.
And the idea that there's plenty for everybody and that working together can be
much more satisfying and you're,
you're much happier if your friends are doing well as much as you are.
Yeah.
In fact,
one of our,
um,
uh,
Shawna haylight when,
if our board of directors who recently died was a brilliant computer guy and he
kept trying to say that,
that we should try to think from abundance rather than from constant need.
And Yeah.
Well that's a,
that's a,
just a,
a general principle of life.
Famine mentalities are terrible way of approaching life and that's the way a lot
of people approach life.
They approach life as if there's a finite amount of resources and they have to
get theirs.
And that's what leads to people cheating on their taxes.
That's a reason people lying,
trying to steal money and stealing money from their employers and shit along
those lines.
They're coming from,
from a,
a standpoint of famine.
Like there's stockpiling nuts for the winter,
right?
They're not as comfortable about their ability to generate new resources.
And that's,
that's a terrible mentality.
And that is a mentality and that,
that sort of,
those sort of philosophies and those ideas can be reinforced or they can,
the opposite can be reinforced.
Uh,
uh,
generous bountiful mentality can be enforced as well.
Yeah.
Well for us,
I mean,
it's going to be 15 to $20 million to make Mtma into a medicine.
And the same for Psilocybin or LSD and we don't have all that money.
It's crazy.
But it caused pharmaceutical companies way,
way more than that.
It should cost the amount that it costs to get one guy high on Mtma.
He should do it and go,
oh,
listen to me and make it legal for us.
Just stop.
Stop the bullshit.
Yeah.
But we've had to have that attitude that the resources are out there.
And once we can demonstrate that we can use them wisely as we grow,
the resources will grow.
And so far,
you know,
we're in our 27th year and that's what's what's happening.
How happy are you now that you're seeing all this like really tangible progress,
real tangible progress,
very happy.
But I'm also,
uh,
because I woke up to all this in 1971 and 72 right after the backlash.
Um,
I'm concerned a lot.
I'm trying to be very sensitive about another backlash today.
I think it's possible.
I don't think it's impossible.
I don't think it's likely right now.
It just seems,
it seems like the information,
it's just too prevalent.
Well,
but how would you explain the fact that we can't even do marijuana research?
Maybe there's a massive repression.
And so if all those people should be in jail,
that's really what should happen.
Someone should realize what's going on and start locking people up.
And I go,
let's play your game because what you're doing is ridiculous.
You're ruining people's lives for something that really should not be your
choice.
It should not be another person's choice whether or not they masturbate.
And it should not be another person's choice whether or not they smoke pot.
And it's really along the same lines.
Yeah,
well I'm not so sympathetic with putting them in jail,
but I would like to take the source of their power,
which is people's fear that they've generated and others and try to get more.
That's why I'm so glad to be talking with you in this,
you know,
podcasts to people to try to educate them to,
to realize that there is a way where we can work together and make things
better.
I agree.
But I think the people that have done things that have put people in jail for
things along those lines for,
for selling pot or for growing pot or from owning pot there,
they're criminals.
Those are societal criminals.
Well,
I'd say that they have a bridge to other people's human rights without a doubt.
And they have done so with full cultural support.
And I think the way to move forward is not to be so punitive for those that did
it.
Although for some,
I mean,
uh,
but,
but to talk about evolution and to talk about how a different approach is
necessary.
And you know,
whenever I'm in Alaska,
when there was a medical marijuana legalization bill one of the first years ago,
there was this whole idea of reparations to pay people that were in jail and the
polling that was done by the politic,
by the people trying to pass this initiative.
Um,
it showed that that was a really weak part.
So where you try to impose these penalties on people for past behavior that at
time was sort of socially sanctioned.
What I meant by that was the,
the people that are actively working like privatized prison unions and things
along those lines,
working to keep these drugs illegal so that they profit and that's creepy.
There's,
yeah,
there's some real reprehensible shit that's going on.
It's not as simple as they're acting within culturally defined rules and
regulations.
There's some behind the scenes shady shit that's based on deception.
Well that the stuff like that is should be illegal,
you know?
But I think that the corporate capitalistic approach that we have does permit
that
kind of stuff.
And it permits lobbying congress and it permits this,
this process where people try to get their own interests advanced sometimes over
the interests of others.
And isn't it fascinating that,
I don't know if you feel like this,
but that the thing that would fix the woes that society has more than anything
is a thing that these people were trying to keep from becoming legal.
I,
that might be the big race.
The big race might be recognizing that there are some fantastic tools to change
the consciousness of this culture.
Right.
And I think that idea of thinking about them as tools is really the crucial
distinction because they're not good or bad in and of themselves.
It's how they're used.
And our whole drug policy is,
there's good,
bad,
good drugs and bad drugs,
bad drugs are illegal and good drugs and get a burger king.
Yeah.
Or from the pharmaceutical company.
But it's all about good and bad when it's actually how you use it.
And even the drug that was demonized the most in a way in the 50s in the 60s was
thalidomide.
The drug that was the medical drug that caused birth defects in babies.
And the FDA stopped that in the u s but it was prevalent throughout Europe.
And now thalidomide has become a Madison and the same kind of shrinking of blood
vessels and things.
It's used in leprosy and it's used in cancer treatment.
So a drug that was among the most demonized of all has now been approved by the
FDA with certain kinds of safety procedures to make sure pregnant women don't
get it.
But it's the idea that these are tools and we have the ability to approach these
tools in an intelligent way and a respectful way or in a reckless way.
And what we want to do is try to change these value judgments and prohibition,
support people's human rights to explore their own consciousness.
Uh,
they have freedom of thought and to find a way to integrate into a society
that's moving forward.
How do you do that?
By getting through the corruption because that's the only thing that's holding
it back.
Really the only thing holding it back is corruption at this point with the
amount of data that's been accumulated on medical marijuana.
Well,
okay.
It,
the amount of data that's been accumulated,
the,
the government has been effective.
The,
the DEA parts of the government Niva in preventing what's called the phase three
studies,
the large scale definitive studies that by law congress has created,
FDA must have to prove safety and efficacy.
So at this moment there is not enough data of the kind that the FDA uses for any
other drug.
And if we accept the idea that the FDA should regulate marijuana and
psychedelics,
like they do any other drug,
then we have to acknowledge that there's not enough research for the FDA to
approve it.
It's people twist it and say the FDA has rejected marijuana as a medicine,
which they have not.
We just don't have enough research that way and they won't allow you to do phase
through research.
And so that's why the states,
I think have enough evidence to make it legal and patients and doctors have
enough evidence to decide to try it.
It's just that in our system that we've created to try to make it so that
through science we don't just see what we want to see,
but we kind of have a closer view of what's there.
There are these procedures that still need to be undertaken for marijuana and
also from an May.
So that's why I say we're probably 10 years away from making Mtma into a
medicine and I think we'd be five,
six years away from making marijuana into an FDA approved medicine if the
repression would be lifted right today.
Now,
what are the,
what is the difference between the stage that the FDA FDA requires and the data
that has been accumulated?
Well for,
there's the preclinical stage,
so what that means is preclinical clinical means humans.
So there's a whole series of animal studies looking at toxicity that are
required by the FDA before you can get a drug into humans.
Once you've done that,
then there's phase one,
two,
three and four and phase one is working with people who are not patients who are
healthy volunteers to try to categorize what the drug does and what it does at
different doses.
And for certain drugs that are especially toxic like cancer drugs,
they have like phase one,
a phase two where it's a combination where the drug is so dangerous that it only
can be used in patients.
And so you do these dose finding studies,
looking at the side effects and it in general,
that's what phase one is.
Phase two is where you start working with patients and you start seeing what
does it do?
What is it good for?
How good is it?
What are your measures?
How well did your measures work?
How do you do the double blind to make sure you're not seeing what you want to
see?
What is your scientific methodology for the studies?
Um,
what is your treatment approach?
What dose are you using?
The,
that's for phase two.
And that can take years and years and years.
I mean we've been phase to,
uh,
for Mtma for,
about nine years so far.
Wow.
Yeah.
Starting in 2004 is when we got the first permit.
We actually had permission in 2000 from 2000 and 2001 in Spain for Mtma for
PTSD.
And we had some media attention that was very positive on the radio and the main
TV and newspapers and radio and it motivated the anti-drug authority,
the forces of oppression to shut the study down.
And we weren't powerful enough to overcome it in Spain.
And that's where it was first started though with a study that,
that we were working with women survivors of rape with.
Okay.
But then you've got phase two.
So then once you have figured out your designs and the magnitude and the
variance of the effect,
how strong is it and how common is it?
Is there a large number of people that don't respond at all or do most people
respond then you can size your phase three studies?
So with marijuana,
we have enormous amount of information up to the phase two level and the FDA
will have more information about marijuana Mtma LSD than about any other drug
that they've ever approved in their entire history.
And the reason is because they,
the research is usually done with hundreds or thousands of people.
10,000 is about as high as you go.
But we've had LSD used by tens of millions of people and marijuana by hundreds
of millions of people.
And we know the one,
one in a million side effects or the one in 5 million side effect that we only
discover from pharmaceutical drugs once they're approved.
So it would not take a long time.
We already know that we would work with marijuana,
with a nausea control for cancer,
chemotherapy,
marijuana for pain,
particularly for people on opiates because we've already shown in phase two
studies funded by the state of California that when you combine marijuana with,
uh,
opiates,
that people get better pain control and they don't need as much of the opiates
and because of Oxycontin and all these big concerns.
So we know the areas that we would study with marijuana and we know the safety
profile.
So we mainly need to just do studies and 200 5,500 people to look at the
particular patient groups that we want to approve.
We have to get high quality standardized medical grade marijuana to do it in.
Um,
and so maybe we're five years away if the political barriers were removed right
today,
which they're not.
What happens
to someone that takes LSD and goes crazy because I've had many people tell me
stories.
I know the Syd Barrett story from a pink Floyd is a famous one.
I don't know if it's true,
but that was the word was that he had taken too much acid and lost his mind.
I think it's possible,
but it depends on the supporters context.
And before you ask them about the candy flipping about MDA,
Lsd,
so in in the future when people are having this very difficult LSD experience,
maybe they go to the emergency room or something.
Adding Mtma takes it from this terrifying sense of dying.
You go destruction and grounds it so that people can work through it.
So I think that LSD has that potential to destabilize people but in a supportive
environment that can be helpful and handled in support it.
So that's fascinating.
The candy flipping aspect over the adding end VMA might mitigate some of the
negative effects of the stress that you could get from the,
the acid experience.
Oh yeah.
Completely.
Yeah.
And then you can,
so you know,
one possible,
um,
thing we would like to study one day would be to take people who are dying and
start them like we did in Switzerland.
Start them with LSD and four later administer MTMA.
So that way LSD peaks in around three and a half hours,
three,
three and a half hours.
So they go through the whole challenging Lsd of letting go of opening up and
it's,
you know,
hopefully they can make it through that.
And then at the four hours you give Mtma and then everything softens and they
can take it in more.
And then they integrate as they're coming down.
Oh,
so you ride one wave run to the next year,
or if they're flipping out,
if it's too painful or too difficult for them,
maybe at the one at the two hours you could administer it Mtma there and you
don't even have to minister full dose of MD May.
It'd be like a half dose of Md Mace softens it somewhat because they have a
synergistic effect.
Yeah,
they do.
They do.
They go the two of them together.
What's the difference between,
well,
it's more like,
um,
there,
there's an expansion aspect to it,
but there's a grounding aspect as well.
So you think that's a really good combination then?
That's how I,
I think it is.
Yeah.
On the other hand,
for,
um,
you know,
sometimes for spiritual purposes,
let's say,
uh,
where people are looking for this ego dissolution,
um,
you know,
you start with Lsd,
you start with Psilocybin,
you know,
sometimes the experiences last day,
10,
10 hours or more.
Sometimes if you don't fully,
if you open up to the energy flowing through you,
then the psychedelic experience tends to take a shorter amount of time.
And if you end into this resistance,
because for whatever reasons it's really difficult.
It prolongs the experience and once you enter into those kinds of places,
if you were to add Mtma,
then people can integrate it more helpfully.
Have you done any studies,
like with the differences between like hippie flipping and candy flipping using
mushrooms instead of,
uh,
is there any difference to that or,
well again,
we haven't done any studies,
right?
This can't be because combining drugs but more or less it's,
it's similar.
MTMA blends with ketamine,
even MTMA grounds people with ketamine ground shame.
Why not about it?
What did it,
it's probably going to turn out to be like a jack and coke.
Well people were like,
why didn't you guys do this?
From the beginning it was my favorite thing in college.
It was so hard to find.
But when you did you,
you bought a lot and you just saved,
you sat on this.
How did you do it?
Did in terms of the timing,
cause I I'm talking about where,
you know,
did you take them both at the same time or actually a designed together where it
was like,
it was like a candy where it had both of the chemicals in it.
That's the only way I've ever done it.
Now I've done it since then but done it separately with mushrooms and then just
taking,
you know,
uh,
yeah I think it was,
I took it when I was peaking.
I would dose myself with the Mali,
which would then take whatever an hour or so 45 minutes later you'd start
feeling it.
But yeah,
it's great.
I love those two together.
If you need any,
if there's a way to sign up to any of your things,
let me know.
I was robbed by gunpoint so I got the post traumatic stress if you need that.
Well we need people to be,
it's not as easy as getting a prescription for marijuana to get a nurse study
sheet.
We have independent raters.
She would have to have treatment resistant means you have to have had PTSD and
diagnosis.
Very minor compared to like a soldier PTSD too.
They're dealing with real debilitating issues.
You just got freaked out one night.
Well I got a gun in my chest and I thought I was going to die and it was,
I scared of black people for six months and it still comes back to me once in a
while when it's dark out.
Right,
right.
Well people can sign up online to donate to maps because we're funded by
individuals.
The pharmaceutical companies aren't interested because these drugs are off
patent and they're only offered a few times.
So far we've not been able to get a government grant,
although we are working with the national instead of mental health.
And we are,
uh,
Senator Rockefeller from West Virginia recently sent a letter to the assistant
secretary of defense for health affairs,
um,
saying that,
uh,
MDA PTSD research should be looked into.
So,
but we have yet to obtain any kind of federal funding or pharmaceutical funding
or major pharmaceutical or major foundations.
So we're more individuals and family foundations trying to bring this,
um,
research forward.
Well,
I think what you're doing is awesome cause you,
you,
you guys are bringing legitimacy to this.
It would never be done by guys like Brian or myself and a or any of the other
people that are out there enjoying the fruits of your labor.
And the fact that these doors have been broken down now on or open,
I should say,
and work is being done and evidence is being put forth that really can't be
refuted anymore.
It's slowly but slowly starting to accumulate.
Yeah.
I would say that this can't be refuted.
We're right now we're at this stage where we have to replicate our results
because that's the key part of science.
You,
you may have done it once,
but can you do it again and again and again?
And that's where we have still to prove.
So we haven't completely proven our case yet.
Uh,
but it's,
you know,
moving,
we hope in that direction.
Oh,
that's awesome man.
And I think,
uh,
I think there's really exciting things coming up.
I really do.
I feel like our culture is starting to shift.
And a,
I think it's stuff like what you're doing is a big part of that.
Getting that information,
having that on the Internet land,
allowing people to share links,
allowing people to go to,
whether it's maps.org or any of the different website.
erowid.org era was a great website.
Their fiscal
sponsor,
we went to college together.
We try to help other organizations in that way.
Um,
I think this idea of getting honest information out for people to make their own
decisions.
Yeah,
that's what we're about.
It's a matter of time,
right?
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Well my dad is hilarious.
My Dad is 86 and three quarters and he sent me an email today and it said,
uh,
here's a link to an about a marijuana reform.
And he said,
oh,
it's going to be legal in my lifetime.
Wow.
I was like,
Dad.
I said,
I hope you're right.
You know,
even if you have to live another 20 years,
I would have never thought in 2013 it was still being illegal.
And when I was a kid,
I would,
I thought it was a matter of time.
Well,
I was on the board of normal for awhile,
quite awhile and I was with people who started normal in 1970 and 71 and thought
it would be legal in a few years.
So that sort of temper is my,
uh,
sense of time to be with people who,
you know,
over 40 years ago thought it was only going to be a few years away that
marijuana would be legal.
Unfortunately they're still working to try to help bring that about.
Do you lose enthusiasm sometimes when you see that it's still illegal after all
this?
No,
it's the um,
it's about,
it's a worthy,
like on a worthy opponent.
It's a worthy goal.
And so I think we just do what we want to do.
There's times when I felt like I was so blocked that I needed to do something
where I could actually see change.
And so I stopped work for a week and painted my house
and that was great.
That's real.
Must must get some feel like you're spinning your wheels sometimes.
Well for years and we just spent four years with a Health Canada to trying to
get an import export permit to bring in eight grams of MDA.
And this is after Health Canada had approved the protocol and our IRB had
approved of protocol and the,
uh,
four years it took and they went through all these ridiculous things about the
pharmacy had to have bulletproof glass,
it had to have all these alarm systems,
class people are going to come in and steal your eight grams of acid.
That was eight grams.
Yeah.
That would be in a safe and the safe had to be disguised in a wooden cabinet and
the safe had to be bolted to them before they went harder than the u s it was
ridiculous.
But we eventually,
you know,
prevailed.
We just took every ridiculous thing and we did it.
I mean,
my policy is surrender.
You know,
when there's certain kinds of irrational things coming from people who are more
powerful,
try to give it to them.
Well that's probably why you're in the position that you're in your facilitator
of this.
I'm willing to dialogue venture forth.
Yeah.
And there are parts that are exciting,
that are connections that you know,
are just coming together.
Like even for the national incident mental health there,
there was a,
um,
uh,
in the late 1980s,
the fellow who's the current head of the nationalist of mental health was doing
Mtma neurotoxicity research in animals.
And I visited him and he was,
um,
you know,
this sort of hidden away in the countryside animal research lab to,
not attract all these animal rights protesters.
And we had to go through all his guards and Barb wire and stuff.
But he seemed like he was sincerely interested in the question and wasn't trying
to twist the results to justify the drug war.
And we developed a respect.
I certainly respected him.
And about two years ago,
year and a half ago,
I wrote him an email and I hadn't talked to him.
And since that point he's now become the head of the national incident mental
health.
And I just said,
is now a good time to apply for a grant for MD May,
PTSD research or is it so politically hot?
It's just not worth it.
And he said,
now is the time.
And he appointed someone else inside the Nmh who is an expert at PTSD to help us
prepare applications that are more likely to be accepted.
But what he did say is that the actual decisions are made by peer reviewers,
the way they've set up for government money to be distributed,
that they bring in the scientist.
And he said the system of peer review as well known not to be sympathetic with
innovation.
So even though we have all the support,
it's still may not work.
It's hard to get systems to accept innovation and change.
What can people at home that are listening to this podcast or watching it,
what can they do to,
to help you to help keep this momentum going?
Well,
first off,
become a member.
Um,
sign up for a monthly membership.
we just had the incredible conference.
We're a psychedelic science 2013 largest psychedelic conference that we've ever
had in the u s over 1900 people.
There's a whole,
I WASC attract the biggest Iowasca,
uh,
conference ever and clinical research.
And um,
I was approached by a more Amara,
this group that helps groups crowdsource a transcription and translation of
these talks and videos are not searchable on Google,
but when you do a transcript or if you do transcript of the shows,
people can then search on the transcripts in that gets them to the video.
So people,
if they're interested,
and it would be a tremendous thing for them to learn to,
to go to the maps website,
map s.org to our psychedelic science 2013 conference page and you could sign up
if you wanted to listen to some of these lectures,
which are tremendous and transcribe or translate them if you know other
languages.
Awesome.
Yeah,
there's other things people could do.
I just have a Twitter page.
We have Twitter,
we have a map maps.
News apps do is,
yeah,
we have a tremendous social media team already.
Remember we are going to do a Indiegogo campaign starting probably in a week or
so to raise $10,000 for the Zendo project at burning man are harm reduction
program so people could tell other people about that.
And then we're going to go,
as we said earlier,
to a probably a $250,000 request for the study with veterans with Mtma.
Um,
I think people can come out to their families,
people can come out to people that they just talk about and not be so reticent
if psychedelics been helpful or even if they've not been helpful,
you know,
to talk about how,
what they learned about,
about what they think are these tools.
Maybe they use them poorly,
maybe they used them well,
but I think look at the gay rights movement and
thinking about this,
the wrong tool for the wrong job too because they didn't have education about
it.
Yeah.
And we're finding that people that sometimes you psychedelics at festivals for
what I would say is the wrong reason,
just to have a fun time and not the right reason.
Well you told us it's beautiful,
but I think you have to be ready for the difficult stuff.
And if you're trying to suppress the difficult stuff,
that's when people get into trouble.
You should have more joking around.
But I think the celebratory use is really important.
And that's why for us medicalization is not the for maps as a five o one c three
not change to change the laws.
We're about medicalization.
But I think as a society we need spiritual use.
We need personal growth,
creativity.
We need a broader drug policy,
which would have adults have the right to use psychedelics.
I think it would be like the driver's license model where you would perhaps have
a certain education,
you have to pass a test and maybe even to start out.
So we avoid backlash.
There would be psychedelic clinics where you would go have an experience under
supervision and if you did it well,
uh,
meaning you didn't totally flip out or you know,
then you would have the right to buy it on your own.
And I think what we would do with children,
I think drugs would be illegal for minors,
legal for adults.
But 23 states in the United States have a parental override for alcohol that if
you want to give your kid alcohol in 23 states,
you can do that.
And I think that that's how we handle under h is that we leave it,
not the government prohibited at all,
but that it's families decide among themselves how they want to handle it.
That's awesome.
One more question then I'm gonna let you go.
Uh,
Terence Mckenna's stoned ape theory was a fascinating,
the proposal that human beings evolved from lower hominids because we got in
contact with psychedelic mushrooms and his theory,
I don't know if it's correct,
but according to him and his brother,
his brother,
um,
if you just Google search the,
uh,
Dennis Mckenna podcast,
I don't remember which number it is.
You can find it pretty easily and it with a quick search.
But he gave some really interesting scientific reasons for why he believes it's,
it's a very possible that that's what happened.
The doubling of the human brain size over a period of 2 million years.
All this attributed to sy silicide.
Well,
Dennis was one of the speakers at the conference and so people could actually
translate and transcribe his talk if they wanted.
Awesome.
Beautiful.
But I think that the,
the,
the deeper question is can the apes that we are today evolve further with
mushrooms?
And I think answer to that is clearly
yes clear whether the apes of several million years or a hundred thousand years
ago it used mushrooms.
It's certainly plausible and I hard to say one way or the other.
I am not in a position to say I believe it or not.
I think Terrence said some things that were pretty um,
exaggerated.
Like this whole idea that the end of the Mayan calendar was going to be the end
of the world.
And while I was in a cable,
well he talked about a massive constants in a shift and it would all be
different and like per space,
he talked about that we were going to reach a point of technological
singularity.
He thought that we were going to reach a point of infinite novelty and that
right tracking it with his TimeWave zero algorithm that he created,
he created this really sketchy thing when he was on mushrooms because based on
the each thing that's supposedly a map novelty or human innovation that you
could put it through a graph.
But I think when you get really fucking high,
you could see patterns in almost anything.
Yes.
And he had this,
this eating pattern that he had chased down for like 20 plus years in created a
formal mathematical program.
He had some,
uh,
mathematical experts actually engaged him in dialogue and one's in disagreement,
right?
Yeah.
So I think if,
if you know,
Dennis Mckenna just wrote a book brothers at the screaming abyss and there's a
good discussion about some of the criticism and the value of time wave zero.
So I was actually,
Terrance was the one that started help start MTMA research because we were at a
conference at Esselyn,
it was in 1983 and it was already clear because of Dallas and stuff that Mtma
was being used in public setting.
And that the crackdown would come.
And so the underground therapists and the shoguns chemists,
so we had this meeting to figure out what to do.
Um,
and Terrence was like,
forget about Mtma it's from the lab.
It's gotta be a plant,
you know,
mushrooms,
thousands of years,
plants are better,
you know,
we can trust them,
they're from nature and you know,
and look at all these risks of Mtma and all this stuff.
And I was like,
well,
I don't see these risks.
And so,
um,
and I also don't believe that plants are drugs from plants are inherently better
tools that,
that we're part of nature that comes from the human mind is out there.
So I said,
I'll put up $1,000 towards an MDA study.
We'll see how risky it really is.
And then Dick Price,
who founded Eslan like 30 seconds,
10 seconds later,
said,
I'll put up a thousand hours.
And so it was in response to Terrence going on about plant medicines being best
and MD may being super dangerous that we did this study and kept it quiet until
the DEA moved to criminalize.
And then we surfaced with the study.
That's interesting.
Well that's great.
Yeah,
that's very funny.
I've always wanted to hear different people's take on that fear because I
thought it was a fascinating theory.
The idea that humans became us because of psychedelics.
And the best culprit is mushrooms because they're like sort of built in.
You don't have to cook and you have to do anything weird.
You don't have to,
you know,
extract anything,
just chew away and boom,
here comes the boom.
Well,
I felt when I had my bar Mitzvah when I was 13 it did not turn me into a man
coming of age.
That's a really unrealistic expectation to 13 shit.
I mean I was the oldest of four.
That's what my parents,
so that's what I expect.
That belt went,
came up with that back when people only live in to be 30 yeah.
So when I,
and I was disappointed,
I was the same.
It was really Bauer.
I was like,
I remember being in bed for the whole week and I'm thinking a lot of people must
have had their bar mitzvahs that day and God must be slow.
And he'll come around to me eventually.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
You know,
and then finally,
nothing happened.
And I just was sad about it.
But when I took LSD for the first time,
I felt that it touched the parts of my psyche that I had hoped my bar Mitzvah
would touch.
Wow.
That was d better than Barmitzvahs next
you got to mean so far the show.
Well,
thank you very much,
Rick.
This is a really awesome glad we could pull it off to spite the gay pride parade
in the Illuminati.
Trying to hold it back.
I made it happen.
Go to maps.org Ladies and gentlemen,
and uh,
what is it?
Maps,
uh,
news on Twitter.
Please follow that as well.
And Facebook.
And let's do this again sometime.
Yeah,
I figured have done it three hours if I wasn't so tired.
Yeah.
Well,
I uh,
maybe you should have tried modafinil.
I want to sleep.
Thank you.
Everybody
tuned into the podcast.
Thanks to Ting for sponsoring us.
Go to a rogan.ting.com and save yourself some cash or an awesome company.
Thanks also to audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe four your free
audio book and 30 days free of honorable service.
And thanks also to legal zoom.
If you use the code name Rogan in the referral box,
you could save some cash.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they provide self help services at your specific direction.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com that's o n N.
I t.
Use the code named Rogan and save yourself some money.
Uh,
we will be back some day this week.
I'm working carets the hours,
so I,
I hardly know what day it is or what's up.
Um,
I'm a mess lately,
but um,
we'll see freaks in Vegas.
Look,
Joey Diaz and I are playing in Vegas at the joint,
uh,
in the hard rock this Friday night.
There's some tickets still available and uh,
it should be an awesome weekend cause it's a UFC weekend.
So that's July 5th,
Friday night,
the joint in Hollywood.
All right,
we love you and we'll see you soon.
[inaudible].